de la compétition qui vont commencer
maintenant alors j'ai pas la bonne
couleur d'échiquier je suis en train de
m'en rendre compte on va remettre ça en
violet ce moment les couleurs les
couleurs changent souvent
et donc aujourd'hui le viol et le viol
et le violet qui va partir et elle est
partie alors quel match on va se
regarder en premier ce que vous voulez
regarder on va regarder le match de goût
nina contre koné ou quand même parce que
parce que ça ça peut assurer la qualif à
100% pour vanina cette histoire et à
conejo elle joue pour plus rien mais de
l'autre côté j'ai du mal à voir une une
quelconque surprise dans le match 2 de
willy fans contre abdou maliki ça me
paraît être très très déséquilibrée donc
on va on va se focaliser sur sur ce
premier match et on verra suivant
comment ça se passe si on change
et voilà les matches qui sont partis je
vais vérifier que tout marche bien à
côté
côté spectateurs qu'on est bien tout le
truc qui marche
ouais chaise comme fr qui vient de de
partir la via une seconde on est live
depuis un peu plus de temps mais ils
viennent de le voir depuis une seconde
et donc ce match qui part avec
directement une semi tarrach un pur pour
alexandra pour valentina pardon je me
trompe de près non ça ne va plus ouais
et donc avec cette grande fougue et 4
prend des deux reste avec des grandes
variantes ces grands rock avec le
cavalier qui peut revenir par la suite
en f 6 on avait vu une partie aux
caisses et si ceci possible pour
attaquer des cats on a vu une partie de
kasparov contre somme il ya un long
moment dans une variante un peu
similaire et je pense que c'était dans
les steppes ans les candidats il ya
trois ans qui avait eu pas mal pas mal
de positions comme comme celle ci donc
la b6 ps a donc envoyé à voir le centre
pour un petit koné roues et l'attaquent
du centre pour pour valentina valentina
valentina quand même favorite du match
même si même si elle est lougheed allez
un petit peu derrière elle est censée
être très favorite de ce match donc
contre contre koné roues koné rookie qui
est plus forte qu'elle en partie longue
mais mais en blitz et d'autant plus sur
internet
il semble que valentina soit plus forte
en d'ailleurs c'est elle la leader des
grands prix elle a rattrapé ou chez nina
et si elle ya une ce match elle sera
déjà je crois bien mathématiquement
qualifiés pour la finale faudra tout de
même vérifier les
autres résultats et je vais juste jeter
un oeil pour être bien sûr que ce soit
partie parce que
je vais voir je vois personne dans le
chat pour le moment non si c'est bon
c'est bien parti mais juste personnes
dans le chat parce qu'il n'y a personne
derrière pearson sur la chaîne en
anglais non plus quasiment par rapport
au fait qu'il ya des des premières pages
au poignet en portugais et en espagnol
ni nulle part donc ça va ça va on est à
on est bien il ya personne chez nous il
ya personne chez les autres c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas de notre de notre
ressort et donc h4 qui vient d'être
jouée par par les blancs doux qui met la
pression un petit peu sur l'ale de duroy
donc pour préparer des cavaliers h5 et
les noirs qui joue cavalier c4 donc qui
viennent viser la dame en d2 la dame qui
repart en hausse de donc qui attaquent
maintenant le cavalier c4 et les noirs
qui vont peut-être le protéger par
bessin qui avec l'idée peut-être un jour
de faire dame à cinq ou même peut-être à
5 x 6 b 4 si on veut faire une une
expansion allèles dame en tout cas ça
peut être déjà une première idée
cavaliers des six ça paraît un peu
bizarre on va peut-être pas partir pour
ça on va peut-être pas partir pour sa
baie 5 paraît quand même assez logique
hein après il faut que si regardez les
tours b 1-1 tombé à 6 francs ces caméras
tours france et quatre pour jouer sur ce
courage et salua do you be salue donc à
11 9 9 9 ludo chess guillot ina et low
key qui repartent y en a 5 du coudon
carélie c4 était pas forcément le coup
de l'année on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi la paf et b5 sur dame de je
vais je vais allumer leur dis pas ce que
je vois pas mais doit y avoir une raison
alors non il n'y a pas vraiment de
raison
qu'elles aient à s'inquiéter le coût de
leur dis mais ça veut dire que yahia n'y
a pas de ya pas de fil conducteur dans
ce qu'elle a fait avec près l'éviter
d'un f4 et salua pierre-louis pk y est à
raffi 94 94 représente représente donc
le quart eli qui est reparti sur cette
case à 5 et les blancs qui vont devoir
tenter de mener l'attaqué allait le roi
alors on pourrait faire des prises du
centre avec de5 un peu comme on l'a vu
dans la master class d'hier le problème
ici c'est que le fou contrôler la case e
4 et est donc belle et nord ou pour
affaire d'âme des cinq occuper cette
caste des 5 et les blancs pourront pas
profiter de la case 4 et salua zige
merci tout à l'heure pour les cinq saab
yg je crois qu'ils sont passés s'est
passé à las le le remerciement du d5
seube
merci pour les 500 cadeaux je tenais à
te remercier
du coup dès que je te voyais dans le
tchat et ça tombe bien puisque c'est
chose faite et salua sprick l'idof que
l'on cache 5h six mois peut-être un coup
un truc thématiques dans cette position
là c'est des cinq puis on prend et e5
avec l'idée de jouer qu'ils avaient des
cats et de mener les attaques allaient
droit ça ça peut être thématiques et sur
des 4 on peut prendre en d4 parce que
sur dame prend des cartons à foisches
cet échec qui gagne la dame donc des 5
sera un coup ici très thématiques comme
comme dans la partie kasparov somme elle
a fait dam des deux dames 7
du coup elle n'a pas joué deux des cinq
thématiques c'est dommage damev quatre
tours d1 et ls valentina goût nina
s'organiser elle fait le dessin que
maintenant wayne donc ça elle avait
quand même l'idée est là elle a juste à
la juste place et les pièces un peu
différemment et du cou puis on prend des
5 et e5 donc qui va qui va être jouée
par les blancs
on va voir comment comment ça continue
ça les abris ce sens la route bleue
lisandro kewin sur lebron chevalot il ya
les l'épisode avec l'accent anglais il
ya 12 heures de stream aujourd'hui anne
en enfin il ya eu un stream à 12 heures
c'était une petite tentative du coup et
je pense que je vais dans le futur
tenter de faire une ou deux fois par
semaine des stream entre entre midi et
deux je vais voir comment ça peut
s'organiser mais comme il ya beaucoup de
stream
je me dis ça peut être sympa de temps en
temps de changer l'horaire en fait parce
que sinon tous les stream sont le soir
et j'imagine qu'il ya des gens qui
peuvent pas suivre le soir qui peuvent
suivre que l'après midi et donc je me
dis en prenant la pause déjeuner mais
peut-être je sais pas si c'était bien
partie pédagogique ou d où des blitz
soins variés un petit peu débile s'est
départi pédagogique suivant donc fou b1
et donc ouais sur fion prendre sur la
même idée un de faire re 5 et de se
prendre la case f5 et cavaliers des
quatre cavaliers f5
alors après là il se trouve que sur
pions prend ya peut-être aussi pions
prends parce que y'a la tour dans le
vis-à-vis de la dame ça c'est encore
autre chose mais je veux dire de toute
façon sur puis on prend à eux cinq
serait très fort parce que le roi noir
est vraiment faible
elle n'a pas du tout intérêt à le
prendre mais dézingue tout al heure plus
tôt était plus provocant en fait l'aller
noir réussissent à jouer sans en
encaisser le pion à la robin qui est
déçu qu'on l'appelle pas offert robin
robin robin robin wood qui est déçu
qu'on l'appelle qu'on l'appelle plus
bibi robin bibi robin c'est un beau
pseudo ça tu veux qu'on t'appelle billy
robin plus tôt bill yearwood nokia qui
revient en c4 les blancs qui réussissent
pas à s'installer sur ces cases blanches
elle se défend bien valentina allendale
de qualif en finale par deux en finale
du truc faf pas en finale de ce grand
prix en finale des grands prix pour être
précis et dans l'autre match pour le
moment on est toujours à égalité 0-0 et
donc les gagnantes on peut on peut se
voir le tableau 1
la gagnante de ce match là donc koné
roogoo nina rencontrera la gagnante du
match
arica contre kosteniuk et on peut
imaginer kosteniuk soit favorite même si
à riga sera dangereuse et les amis donc
il ya eu un échange la dame qui en g 4
peut-être à lui essayé d'atterrir en g6
cette dame c'est là qu'on vient thiem du
tour à qui n'en finit pas c'est c'est le
quatrième tournoi qui n'en finit pas et
donc c'est là une deux trois ya cinq
journées par tournoi 10 15 16 17 la dix
septième journée de tournoi la lega à
quelle heure jour à sarah alors elle
jouera à 16 heures sarah sadate donc
tour des quatre mais elle a pas réussi à
s'organiser avec les blancs elle a pas
réussi à organiser une batterie fou tour
sur la diagonale est finalement et
finalement c'est les noirs qui
s'organise fait des idées de l'amf cette
dame proche 5 peuvent arriver
alors la tour qui vient en d1
bons coups comme cavalier cinq ici
paraît logique 1 est ce qu'elle fait
parce que sur cavale et prend il ya dame
prend f2 échec
puis tout reprendre cinq d'avoir un
petit cavalier pour un f3 gpra f3 dame
prend f3a non encore pire j'ai pris avec
trois tours g5
c'est terrible donc dû tout apprendre et
maintenant il ya dame prend des quatre
dames profit trois points f8 au rang des
quatre tours c'est un échec ouais c'est
terrible c'est terrible champion premier
le tour g5 et là autour des huit échecs
intérieurs faisait rien pour ces 1 et
tours prend b1 et un petit koné roula
attention rouages cette paroisse f7 et
petits cônes et rouky à une pièce de
moins alors elle réussit quand même à
récupérer un pion mais un bon bah le fou
qui va venir en c4 le plan b 5 tout est
défendu la tour en b2 qui ont b5 ça va
ça va fuser à elle fait tour à f/5 à
elle veut jouer à fils
elle trouve un tout petit peu de contre
eux je mets un petit roi g8 la termine
termine le con tre jeu très très
simplement
c'est jouer maintenant par par valentina
qui s'est bien assuré de tout protégé du
coup de tourbe est un pur palais ses
pions filet elle va monter roi f4 mais
fou au cices on va tout couvrir ou
tourbe et 5 encore mieux joué de la part
de la joueuse russe
le fou qui revient à f 7 c'est bien roi
g7
allez va falloir taper le pion h5
alors comment fait ce qu'on fait trop h5
qui ont la gagne comme ça c'est facile
ou est ce qu on fait différemment
elle fait différemment elle veut faire
b4 b3 b5 b 4 baies 3par dont 4,4 et ab4
qui va qui va arriver
f5 peut-être elle cherche un patou quoi
mais faudrait contrôler ces deux cases
et c'est pas facile donc ça fait 1 0
pour valentina qui a dominé assez
largement cette première partie je
dirais peut-être une petite occasion
manquée à un moment donné avec un des
cinq pour un petit koné roues mais
mémé valentina qui a fait sa partie qui
est bien installé dans le match
gérer la salle qu'il a vraiment dominé
de la tête et des épaules en match
c'était s'était jouée jones y avait pas
eu ces problèmes de connexion alors et
battu à plate couture et johanne jean
c'est un peu mon regret entre guillemets
de cette compétition c'est dommage
qu'elle n'ait pas pu défendre ses
chances réellement parce que parce
qu'elle en avait largement le niveau de
d'aller loin dans cette compétition donc
là on a une petite petrov alors les
blancs ont repris du plomb des pour
faire dépenser 3 et donc blindés blindés
leur leurs ailes dame rouge et 4h 3 et
donc d'être dam des deux grands requins
ça c'est logique le pion c3 aussi qui
vient souvent ces quatre dans cette
variante pour contrôler la case dessin
qui quelque part les pions doublé pose
pas vraiment problème puisque le pion
c'est cadiens prendre de l'espace et
interdire un petit peu des cinq là la
petite expansion allait le roi qui fait
pas de mal la dame qui atterrit sur la
case dessins qu'elle est centralisé et
le roi qui va qui va filer pour pour le
grand roque et le roi qui va filer pour
pour le grand qu donc le grand qui part
alors on va voir comment ça ça continue
pression sur sur le pion à vii donc ya
pas de grand roque pour pour les noirs
mais peut-être un coup comme dame e66 y
est envisageable pour pour mp sans
prendre un peu à option à 2 au passage
provoquera peut-être dame ci soient pas
venir
ah ok on peut prendre prend d'essayer de
jouer ses pions doublet mais bon il ya
quand même un gros centre côté noir
ça paraît intéressant le ku'damm si si
si elle a fait tout reif 8 donc elle
préfère conserver les dames tourin est
maintenant grand rouquin j'imagine
voilà c'est chose faite c'est jouer le
roi qui va à l'abri le roi blanc qui va
à l'abri aussi donc les deux rois qui
sont qui sont chez cacher qu'à et les
blancs qui vont qui vont tenter
maintenant de jouer peut-être sur cette
caste des quatre avec le cavalier ou
bien jouer un c4 1 peut-être pour jouer
éventuellement même c5 est venu
recasser casser la structure noir ces 4
me semble être le coup qui me qui me
plaire ici pour ça qu'ils aient des cats
au début pour sûr cavale et prend tous
les pions prend à me remettre la
structure à l'endroit elle fait qu'à
rallier de d2 alors cavaliers des de wes
qu'elle veut avec ce cavalier est ce
qu'elle veut rebondir en 1/4 peut-être
pour jeu la casse c5 ou la casse g5
possible f5 joué par mp et sur fgf elle
veut peut-être gf tout simplement pour
se dédoubler les pions et avoir une
meilleure structure parce que le
résultat c'est que les blancs restaurer
avec un pion h3 un petit peu triste donc
f5 jouer f5 jouer on va voir comment
comment elle continue prix sens pas très
intéressant et aussi la f4 à surveiller
puisque ce flou pourrait se retrouver
sans case intéressante pollution en
position somme toute correcte un côté
côté noir et merci a dit commagnac pour
pour le raid de 36 personnes merci à toi
donc fou des quatre elle s'en prend aux
pions g7 à lorient peut être prise en
prison j'ai caprice g4 prise g4 et
surprise g7 eurent appris m2 qui
gagnerait un pion qui semble que pranger
4 gagne simplement un pion pour les
noirs ouverture qui semblait plutôt
réussi pour pour valentina et en
l'espace de quelques coups là elle elle
perd un pion un comédien qui bon serait
bon après-midi bande après matois dit
commagnac et merci pour tout et stream
toujours pleins d'énergie et de bonne
humeur ça fait plaisir
je passerai à faire du jeu geisser un de
ces 4 ou quelque chose du style
en tout cas serait très plaisir de te
regarder un peu sur sur un jeu de ce
type là aussi tout cas bonne
bon après bombe au repos alors alger
alger dame projet 4 comme je vous disais
maintenant si tu prends g7 et f2 en
l'air à la fin parce qu'elle avait
probablement pas bio leur skf trois
intermédiaires
elle fait tour g1 pour faire gaffe ce
qui peut au sort dès qu'il prend des
quatre un jour où contre intermédiaire
donc ce qu'elle veut c'est dame f5 damev
cinq tours f5 et peut-être tour j'ai six
cavaliers des quatre cd4 ou f6 et jouer
cette finale avec un petit désavantage
mais pas de pions de moi ça part comme
ça l'a fait tout reprend c'est
exactement la variante non tout reprend
g6 et cac et prend des quatre prises des
4 x f6 paraît logique un protège le pion
j'ai cette attaque le pion des 4 alors
il prend f2 elle veut faire flouer fils
maintenant alors c'est peut-être un poil
dommage parce que je pense était plutôt
à l'avantagé nord le pion g7
regardez en fait je vous expliquer
pourquoi pourquoi on préférait avoir g7
f2 parce que le pion g7 en fait il fait
une synergie avec le fou il protège le
fouet le full protège il faut une
synergie alors que le pion f2 il est
sous attaque et le cavalier peut pas
faire de synergies avec donc quelque
part on perd une synergie en faisant
tourner - f2 et fo f6 jeu précis c'est
compréhensible un mais mais du coup tu
préférais avoir ce petit truc qui était
bien cependant c'est toujours mieux pour
les noirs parce que l'eia latour
deuxième il ya le fou qui couvre la case
d'entrée en g7 pour la tour blanche et
tourage de une menace et on n'a pas le
temps de faire tour f 1 tour prend des
deux tours f6 tourage deux essais les
noirs qui arrive largement premier sur
la seconde et ça c est un avantage ou là
y'avait même tous rachats que j'ai raté
qui faisait carrément maths mais quoi
qu'il en soit tous rage 2 suffisait déjà
du coup aux blancs de jouer
voir ce que fait ce que fait vanina
voir ce que je vaux vanilla elle joue
tour g3 il va y avoir tour hh 2 je suis
avec le redis ça dépend pour vérifier
ouais mais je regarde pas à pas du tout
les coups et les éval mais juste pour
vérifier des fois je regarde juste il ya
un truc qui bouge beaucoup et si je me
trompe pas dans une variante mais non je
dis plutôt les coûts qui me gêne mais là
c'est que des coups très logique car de
toute façon la pression sur le cavalier
roi ces deux logiques et maintenant
lydec les noirs seraient pouvoir ramener
le flou sur cette diagonale h6 c'est un
donc je vous affiche à l'écran pour
mettre la pression sur le cavalier alors
un coup comme x h 4 sera intéressant
elle fait b 6 rbds et 6 5 qui me paraît
bizarre à première vue je comprends que
vous faire ces cinq en fait c'est pas
idiot du tout en vrai il ya une idée
c'était pas le coup que moi j'aurais
joué mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il est
mauvais il est peut-être même meilleur
puisqu'il ya l'idée de jouer avec ses 5
et peut-être un jour ces quatre maîtres
le roi en difficulté il faut s'être joué
un cavalier f3 peut-être un fou des six
peut-être un fou des six cavaliers cinq
tours prend b2 valentina qui joue le
contre eux je en fait tour à je suis toi
elle veut pas elle veut pas se prendre
des échecs et laissez-la tout rentrait
et ça y est valentina à stabiliser la
position et il n'y aura pas de you're a
pas de gain pour pour koné roux ici à
moins d'une erreur mais y'a plus
davantage si lecavalier se dirige vers
eux 5 et le roi noir et réseauter les
tours sont plus sur la deuxième rangée
c'est pas les blancs non plus qui joue
le gain ici un may hamm et ya plus de
y'a plus rien c'est fini
c'est fini à purin pour ni l'une ni
l'autre un le jeu on voit bien en fait
le cavalier le fou se neutralisent
complètement mutuellement genre de
neutralisation des pièces le jeu et que
sur une aile donc c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment mieux pour le fou et c'est même
un poil plus chiant pour les noirs
maintenant faut peut-être courir faire
tout recette ici ouais pour se donner de
l'air avec le roi et les s'est échangé
alors évidemment comme je vous dis
quelqu'un peut gagner il peut y avoir
une magouille il peut y avoir une
arnaque ça c'est possible ça ça peut
arriver c'est le propre même des échecs
que vers je demande erreurs mais c'est
quand même plutôt les noirs qui peut
faire des erreurs mais non parce que mal
autant et parce que à la tour qui
revient sur la sixième le carélien e5 et
quand tu fais tout pour 5 tours prend
ses six échecs on voit on voit un
scénario en fait avec ton j'ai six tours
17 cavaliers ou cinq coups ou les blancs
peuvent gagner maintenant dont j'ai ici
c'est déjà un problème autour des 8 et
maintenant c'est le fou au noir qui est
cloué à cause de ton projet 6 etc les
blancs qui vont pouvoir travailler à
l'ale dame en jouant b 4 à 4 à 5 prendre
de l'espace
kébé cattrall attaque ici saluer marlou
saluant chaîneurs et ciao tristan et la
tour prend ses six assurera 17 il va y
avoir plus on prend et il ya le pion b6
qui va rester en l'air c'est un saint
brais problème ici pour pour la joueuse
indienne qui va perdre b6 en plus de
manière forcée qui va avoir laissé
échapper une bonne position je sais pas
trop dit pourquoi ni comment mais allez
passer d'un avantage à une défaite en
l'espace en l'espace de quelques coups
alors là elle menace quand même attendre
ce qui est toujours agréable
ce qui est toujours agréable autour des
6 3 au 7 e tour g6 pourrait changer
alors est ce qu'elle peut faire pranger
si ce n'est entourage suite c'est plus
logique tourache six tours g8
lp lui elle veut faire le chantage aux
mathes quoi elle veut faire le chantage
aux maths et peut-être tour h6 ton g8
alors il fait sarouel fuite dont j'ai
trois maintenant et tour hh devrait être
trouvée du contre jeu quand même koné
roula sur la deuxième rangée tout
reprend b6 et elle va faire tour ces
deux échecs croix des trois tours prend
b2 tour prend à 6 tours prendre b4
j'imagine ouais c'est chose faite
maintenant tous rêvent trois rois bouge
m elle va tomber
elle est trop lente à l'erea mieux fait
de partir en 8 d'ailleurs ce que là il
ya des tours g6 qui peuvent rodez à
l'effet retour b2 mais elle est trop
lente à la souris kone roux a aimé ça
c'est aussi un problème
ben non mais c'est c'est dégueu ça ça
c'est dégueulasse que la police eut été
complètement nul et et ça se joue à la
souris quoi ces tracks qui quand on a
des compétitions il ya des joueurs qui
sont pas très habitués à internet et qui
sont pas assez rapides
je préférais jouer en 4 + 2 à la rigueur
plutôt que de jouer en cinq plus un
puisque les deux secondes je pense
qu'elle survit avec hélas le fait de
jouer avec une seconde et de la voir
perdre comme ça la pendule moi perso ça
me déçoit un petit peu je sais pas vous
de votre côté
non et qu'elle a plutôt pouvoir d échec
soit en voie du 5 + 0 ou du 3 + 0 et ont
fait du sale et on part sur une
compétition veut voir du sale mais si on
me rajoute temps c'est pas pour que les
gens perdent retour pions contre tours
pions quoi je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage
or après valentine a eu raison de le
faire c'est pas ce n'est pas la question
koné roues et pas assez rapide à la
pendule et ses essais sa vie mais
et jamais dire faut faire un choix soit
c'est 5 + 0 ont fait du sal soit ces
cinq + 2 ou je sais pas mais la 5 + 1 où
les gens peuvent quand même faire du
sale je trouve que c'est ceni a fait
ning pas on n'est pas on n'est pas du
bon côté du truc quoi encore en trois
plus un ça m'embêterait mois mais en 5 +
1 les partis qui se finisse comme ça je
trouve ça dommage autant faire du 3 + 3
à la rigueur ou je sais pas mais pour
les connexions lentes ou mauvais
matériel etc mort quoi là je sais pas si
ça vient de la connexion ou quoi mais
mais en tout cas je trouve ça un peu
regrettable à suivre et alors que willy
fans a aussi pris davantage dans l'autre
match je vois pas du tout jeune sai
abdul malik mettre en danger la numéro
un mondiale
côté valentina le truc c'est que si on
passe à 3 0 vu que conejo a quand même
des problèmes de vitesse le match sera
aussi plié et pas très haut niveau je
vais faire une donation des jambes pour
toi bafoue taille sur ma chaîne perso et
que tu es tu seras la chaîne pat à point
et que tu m le petit seube
du coup c'est un peu le le moyen de
soutenir la chaîne
on n'est pas très très nombreux
aujourd'hui poursuivre pour le moment
encore on et 230 après bon ce qui me
rassure c'est que c'est qu'il ya de
moins en moins de personnes qui suivent
sur toutes les langues
c'est déjà ça va tu peux aller sur mon
tipi et tu trouveras le lien sous les
vidéos youtube
sous n'importe quelle vidéo youtube tu
trouveras le lien le lien précis donc la
manger 4 on sera toujours là pour toi
merci je me faisais un idée de quel
point la compétition était encore suivi
est bon aujourd'hui en fait c'est nous
qui résistons mieux les hôtes ya
vraiment peu de gens qui regardent ça
reviendra pour la finale
peut-être lundi way pour la grande
finale tu pas qu'à leur seigneur j'ai
pas eu de d'annonce et salue alix alix z
à jada voilà peut-être des six noms qui
part avec 17 salaire de faire très mal
non tout réussit sa tour aussi sous 17
encore pire oui donc la valentine à qui
ce fait ce match et honnêtement sur ce
coup d'essai est là quand même savoir ça
m'étonnerait qu'elle rate
honnêtement sur le début de match il ya
quand même une domination pour moi d'un
pico nehru
après ben voilà elle perd une partie
autant dans le dans la partie précédente
dans la partie d'avant elle domine l'anc
youth un qui tombe avec la dame
peut-être elle est assez dominante et et
elle rate aussi donc elle se retrouve à
être mené 2 0 un peu contre le cours du
jeu
la dame cet adam 7 qui accueillent ces
six dames pro b cette dame cette attaque
la tour qui nécessitent pas possible des
sept des huit qui arrive ça va fair game
ça devrait faire game c'est de là qu'ils
abandonnent donc encore une partie en 5
+ 1 il y en aura encore une au buzzer
elle gagne au buzzer
piccone roues donc le match va durer les
amis la cadence va durer c'est rare
qu'ils aient quatre parties en 5 + 1 on
va voir s'ils s'y connait roux réussi à
recoller un même si à l'aller noir je
pense que c'est la cadence qui la
favorisent le plus vu ses problèmes de
lenteur on va voir ce que ça donne un
tour c'est un fou 17 à 3
intéressant un bien fou détroit après
elle retarde le développement du fou
pour retarder le dépenser 4 mais ce coût
peut être utile se peut servir à faire
des bébés cats empêche les fous b4 c'est
plutôt intéressant
bon avec les marques tu fais quoi tu
écris b17 pour le moment façon son
cavalier il n'est pas sur une mauvaise
passe tu pourras jouer du c5 ou tu
pourra prendre en c4 elle prend ces cas
directement
donc elle veut pas laisser le cepr en
dessin qui était probablement l'idée de
de valentina sur cavaliers b17 l échange
elle fait ces cinq maintenant donc pour
venir contre attaqué le centre blanc
rouge et trois jouets se met sur à la
grande diagonale la diagonale pardon du
pal a grandi au point de la diagonale du
système de londres bien placé et a6 qui
peut préparer db5 c4 ou juste db5 cdd 5
dame b si ça va donner aussi une case de
plus à la dame qui a qui manquait de
deux cases
cela peut-être un dan b6 tour ses huit
tours des 8 est assez logique côté noir
mais problème de koné rouge qu'elle
prend trop de temps elle a déjà grillé
quasiment une minute trente
mais quand on sait à quel point le temps
est précieux en fin de partie
c'est peut-être un poil trop mais bon
après les biens sortie de l'ouverture
avec les noirs elle a une position tout
à fait tout à fait corrects ont pris ces
cinq ça va reprendre ses cinq et on va
viser par la suite cette case cette case
donc elle vient elle attaque le cavalier
est là maintenant elle va partir
probablement sur sur la case de 4 la
joueuse indienne
la prix des as
j'ai envie de dire pourquoi pas
intermédiaires et peut-être que le
carélien elle veut le ramener en
décèdent du coup après c'est une autre
possibilité un an disait peut-être que
sur cave a lieu quatre à y avait calé
pour quatre cas il prend 1,4 fous ses
sept tours d un tour d un adam né à
damas est ouest et est un problème est
effectivement d'avis qu'il faut rentrer
en dix-sept donc c'est pour ça avec à
l'appréhender en premier merci le chat
pour pour cette petite aide
après c'est c'est entre guillemets à la
même la même idéal a pris du cavalier
maintenant elle va venir e4 et du coup
elle va pouvoir jouer damas 700 qui est
le problème de la dame blanche qui
rentrent en dix-sept donc ya pas de
dames 17 ici la dame ne peut pas à
rentrer donc en dix-sept façon il n'y
est pas mais de toute façon je leur
parle à qui avait pas de lieu même s'il
avait la veille repris aurait pas eu de
problème de dames 17 ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre donc cavalier des quatre joué
par les blancs vise un peu à la case la
case c6 même beaucoup malvy cette case
ces six cavaliers qui vient en d5
et donc il vise qui vise la case c3 le
fou qui revient en 5 d'accord pour viser
pour viser j'ai cette fois f6 là elle
propose les changes des fous surtout
preuve si sky prend un f6 ça va revenir
au carré lieu pour un f6 même je sais
pas lequel des deux positions assez
garlin assez équilibré et salutaire ian
s p dans le dans le tchat
donc elle reprend f6 il va y avoir des
tours c8 qui vont qui vont arriver
j'imagine autour des 8 même bon cavalier
qui seraient requis se redirige vers ses
seins donc vaut peut-être remettre ce
cavalier e 4 après peut-être trois ou
quatre bref trois possibles au cas sera
pas possible pour le moment parce que
ces clous et mais ça peut se préparer
mais lecavalier en b 6
qu'ils essaient 5 peut-être fou des cinq
très bien joué et surtout prend des cinq
qui prend des cinq puis cavaliers c4
peut-être qui va arriver
je pense assez logique de prendre du
cavalier f mais bon qu'est hébété
jouable aussi mal va remettre le
cavalier ans en f4 j'imagine dam des
deux n'est ce pas si simple qu'elle f4
c'est logique mais ce n'est pas
forcément bon après un petit retard au
temps alors juste regarder le score est
dans l'autre match à un ennemi un ennemi
un agent zahia qui s'accroche à willy
fans qui fait pas la différence
étonnant tam g4s que eu 5 et 1 500 m²
lieu trois cavaliers f5 c'est ça l'idée
de peut-être carélie g6 plus tôt c'est
ça l'idée de valentina donc mal veut
peut-être cavaliers c4 sahel 1 d'essayer
d'imposer son jeu et de mettre ce
cavalier après en f4 plus tard quand la
dame partira qui est pro sys willaya
juste dame 17 non sap erp sap erp une
pièce direct c'est terrible c'est
terrible cette faute tactique de
valentina qui se prend à un clouage à et
c'est terrible
une pièce c'est un cadeau là de la part
de valentina et on disait inquiet en 5 +
1 c'était sa cadence
elle a mon avis plutôt favorisée par par
cette cadence c'est là où elle a le plus
de chance c'est finalement d'avoir cette
partie de plus même s'ils savent avec
les noirs ça lui redonnera en plus les
blancs au début du iii +1 et ça lui
permet de revenir à la marque donc
c'était vraiment plus tôt dans l'intérêt
de valentina un d'essayer de faire durer
la partie précédente par là elle essaye
tant bien que mal de ramener un cavalier
mais mais la partie est complètement
complètement fou tu t'imagines que le
cavalier va venir en c4 est h4 alors
elle veut faire h56 lecavalier par your
adam g 7 matchs carey lieux saints
qu'elle chasse la dame dame g3 est
peut-être pendant du danube 6 mchf h5
très bien ça empêche s'empêche h5 ça
fixe le pion dame j'ai cinq tours c'est
elle veut échanger les tours tours
dernier change pas elle veut viser la
case des huit peut-être un petit coup de
f6 quand même pour chasser mais la dame
repart en g3 avoir même dame prend h5
aussi qu'heroes j'avais complètement
oublié cette menace et c'est pas si
simple
elle va quand même la perdre koné ou
j'annonce une défaite de koné roues d'un
proche cinq années kf4 mais qui avec 400
fermes la dame les amis je ré annonce
une victoire de koné roux dame g5 le
retour il va y avoir les changes des
dames et ça va aller ça va échanger
d'avoir à noter qu'avec le petit module
joie qui a cavalé f3 puis on prend et
cavaliers h3 qui gagne elle le voit très
bien joué un petit qui enchaîne les
tactiques
ça serait quand même sympa de la part de
valentina d'abandonner de pas jouer sur
la connexion adverse
il ya déjà quand même une dame net de -
un petit peu de fair play elle va
peut-être encore un petit peu là jouez
pas d'abandon un sait jamais si la
connexion adverse crack bon mais je
pense qu'elle va abandonner rapidement
elle a peut-être difficile de vivre la
désillusion de la partie la dame des
deux dames prend à 3 effet pas dame
prend 1,3 elle fait dame b3 pour une
raison sombres raisons j'ai envie de
dire elle peut peut-être la faire tomber
quand même rsa qui va être terrible dans
ce match en fait allé moi je sais tu
sais bien joué alors enfin tu prêt move
quelque chose valentina qui va envoyer
au 6 mai bon ouais elle tente tout
valentina elles essayent de résister au
maximum ça continue à jouer ouais bah
elle voit que l'autre est vraiment lente
mais bon la sueur qui a rédigé quatre
tours pranger 4 comprend g4 d'un point f
deux dameuses d'un proxy saturent
il va être temps d'abandonner quand même
valentina sayah l'abandonnent elle a
voulu un petit peu essayé tant qu est le
cavalier de mettre une fourchette
difficile très difficile à le perdre
deux parties vraiment deux partout mais
ouais c'est vraiment sûr sur les échecs
1 c'est vraiment koné rookie qui est
devant d'une bonne tête
elle joue vraiment beaucoup mieux que
que son adversaire 2 2 contre le cours
du match puisque valentina elle menait
déjà 2 0 contre le cours du match et
après valentie
un piia à égaliser j'ai envie de dire
assez tranquillement elle a vraiment
dominé les deux parties là pour
l'égalisation donc un score comme 3
serait vraiment beaucoup plus logique
entre les deux femmes
maintenant j'ai envie de dire le score
le score est tel qu'il l'est il ya deux
partout et les cadences à venir vont
largement favorisé la joueuse russe donc
on va voir si si la joueuse indienne
réussi à se mettre au niveau
mp away pierre on arrive à se faire va
se faire flinguer de partout on verra on
verra si elle a réussi à accélérer
moi je vais partir faire une petite
pause je vous remets comme les dernières
fois
la dernière partie en redif et je
reviens dans de petites minutes a tout
de suite les gars
alors les gars je suis de retour pour
pour ces partis ça vient juste de
reprendre
allez plus de son fusil mal assis avec
le son et l'image mais c'était c'était
la pause donc il ya 2 2 dans ce match je
vous propose qu'on récupère
tranquillement les caméras des des deux
joueuses
allez on va partir on n'a pas les bonnes
cannes tout de suite mais on va partir
on va on va les récupère ça c'est c'est
vanina donc on va la mettre en bas de
l'autre côté on ira chercher à la cam de
koné roues donc ça assez valentina on va
récupérer son nom est donc la partie
c'est une drague aussi dans les amis
enfin pas tout à fait une règle aux îles
mais s'est dans l'esprit de l'arago zine
donc valentina gouina ensuite de son
côté et de l'autre côté ça va être
mpi conejo maintenant qu'on sait que
c'est le match le match qu'on suit et on
va les mettre la caméra dôme puis la
caméra dôme puis elle va être là haut
allez hop
ça c'est fait
c'est n'importe quoi je fais un peu
n'importe quoi là désolé les gars j'ai
fait un peu n'importe quoi mais on y est
on à la caméra d'un outil qui est là
donc cette position elle est un petit
peu mieux pour les blancs pour quelle
raison parce que le fou c'est 8 il a du
mal à s'activer encore et alors que les
blancs ils ont leur toutes leurs pièces
qui sont actifs dont le fou détroit et
là ya peut-être un coup comme fou aux 4
qui peut être cool alors si vous voulez
faire flouer 4 un conseil faites fois je
cet échec d'abord roi bouger fouet 4
après le roi sera toujours un peu moins
bien à schwyz jour où le cavalier
arrivant aux 5
le plan est peut-être un petit peu
fragile et donc normalement faut
toujours faire flasher sept fous et
quatre là d'après moi c'est une petite
erreur de la part de koné route pas
l'avoir fait vlad m'avait donné ce
conseil ready même si t'es pas surfer le
9 fois sur 10 tu auras raison donc faire
le petit x avait cette fois 4 ça peut
être ça peut être sympa pour pour placer
le rang à schmitt
surtout qu'elle a envoyé tout de suite
que quand cavale et bien au sein qui a
une fragilité sur f7 avec laurent h vite
donc c'est un peu dommage mais fou et 4
quand même bien joué
écoutez koné roux qui reste pas trop mal
autant donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour rallier le cavalier qui va arriver
à eux cinq ans elle prend ses 4 alors là
faut pas se prendre une mauvaise blague
comme carey les pros trois fous pro 4 à
un coût de marloux faut éviter les coups
de marloux et peut-être venir alors soit
faire un fou b1 pour essayer de jouer la
diagonale soit faire dame c'est de leur
tour pour jouer cette diagonale là donc
ça dépend ce que jouer sur laquelle tu
veux jouer
celles vers le roi h7 ou celle en
vis-à-vis du fou moi je repartirai
peut-être plus tôt pour dames ces deux
tours c'est un pour jouer pioncer cet
été et ce vis-à-vis et cavaliers 5 et 6
la case c6 mais dommage quand meme de
parapher fourrage cette fouille 4
d'avoir un roi en âge suite ici c'est
quand même dommage
koné roux qui réfléchit mais là qui
réfléchit trop sur un coup comme celui
là est la grille presque une minute et
ça va lui coûter cher en fait ouais là
je pense juste que koné voire aucune
chance de gagner parce qu'elle est trop
lente
c'est une bonne joueuse mais c'est pas
possible c'est juste pas possible et
elle n'a pas elle n'a pas la bonne
pointe de vitesse en fait tu peux faire
ça tu peux faire ce qu'elle est en train
de faire si tu as une excellente pointe
de vitesse mais elle a pas de pointe de
vitesse donc elle va juste perdre toutes
ses parties autant ça va être
désespérant c'est dommage de ne pas
accélérer un petit peu en milieu de jeu
quand même moi je crois c'est un coup un
peu vide et le truc c'est qu'en plus
elle domine pas vraiment dam des trois
c'est bien joué ça elle menace damas est
maintenant là encore un c'est dommage
que le roi soit pas ensuite c'était
vraiment une grosse faute de parents
fait foi h7 fou 4 c'est rare que les
joueurs le fasse pas mais elle a dû
penser qu'il fallait pas le faire pour
une raison x ou y
la différence c'est qu'on menacerait
matin quand même alors que là le roi à
la liberté de repartir donc tous les
coups de type c prend des cats sont
jouables mais je vous ai dit dans un tas
de variantes ça posera problème et ça
n'a pas manqué ça ça donne beaucoup plus
de possibilités à l'adversaire
cavalli f6 pour ces deux animations
avoir tour des huit j'imagine trucks
qu'elle est moins forte en design note
aussi mais elle va perdre autant c'est
dramatique et la ja d'âme des uns qui va
arriver il ya le fou qui tombe c'est
dramatique
[Musique]
ça me prend mieux qu'ils aient tout
reprend et première c'est terrible c'est
dramatique
à faire [ __ ] en f3 c'est fini ouais
c'est vraiment pour moi ce genre de
match c'est le pire scénario de match en
fait qu'on puisse vivre parce que ça tue
un peu l'intérêt de toutes les parties
c'est à dire que quoi qu'il se passe
quoi que tu vois en fait ça se finit pas
aux échecs ou quoi ça se finit juste
parce qu'ils jouissent qui est pas
capable de jouer les coups à la vitesse
requise
et alors là pourquoi ça joue en 5 + 1
c'est terrible c'est pas la bonne
cadence
ça joue pas dans la bonne cadence les
amis pourquoi elle joue en 5 + 1
est-ce qu'ils vont décider de remettre
la partie retarder tous les matches
exane la partie à cause de la cadence et
elle remet temps ça se remet en 5 + 1
c'est terrible c'est de nouveau la
mauvaise cadence c'est terrible et où il
fane mené regev au bord de la dépression
ouais ouais bah c'est comment dire c'est
le genre de ces c'est typiquement c'est
typiquement la les parties viennent and
had viennent d'être annulées 1
c'est typiquement le genre de match que
je trouve assez désagréable à suivre au
final parce que ben en fait ya pas trop
de suspense au final ça joue juste sur
ce quelqu'un qui sait pas bouger la
souris
et c'est parce qu'on veut voir c'est
vraiment le type de match ajoutait topal
ouais c'est vraiment le type de match où
tu vois pas du tout ça peut tourner quoi
à lessard pas maintenant c'est les
mauvaises couleurs
c'est terrible c'est terrible qui vont
devoir annuler la partie une fois encore
a tancé les bonnes couleurs valentine
arriver les noix pardon pardon
qui en d3 et donc à waimes et koné voire
et gagner une partie comme ça ah non
elle avait perdu finalement autant elle
s'était retrouvée mieux mais avait perdu
autant s'ils avaient une fois 5 g4 ou g6
y avait eu un échange et la dame est
arrivée en d5 si vous vous rappelez et
il y avait eu dame 17 les blancs avaient
rien obtenu après tour f8
il y avait eu tout re 1 je pense rock et
les blancs mais joue un plan avec 4,4
al-fekki validé quatre que j'ai proposé
à l'époque d'ailleurs
ouais avec risque et prend des quatre de
reprendre peut-être de ces à moins
qu'ils aient un dame prend 17 ou quoi il
ya même fou prend des cas qui peut être
intéressant pour mettre la pression sur
tous les pions noirs en fait sur
bessette sur a7 sur g7
on voit que les noirs ont du mal à tous
à tout défendre qui est des 4 semble
être un coup assez fort et donc
maintenant il va en échangeant ses six
salles en france et qu'elle prendrait
qu'elle doublerait les pions noirs et
jour et c4 par la suite
assise jouer donc elle enlève le pion à
d'un vis-à-vis désagréable et g5 fixe le
pion g7 en quelque sorte à peu faire h4
est fixé cette structure de pions et
demain sera pas moi qui commentera ce
sera andrea et fabien vous pourrez
profiter du duo je me rappelle qu'à
quelqu'un y est requise et qu'il
préférait les duos du poids
demain vous débarrasserez de moi et vous
aurez droit au duo d'entreprise en déca
de prison décade dame prend des cadres
probablement parce qu'elles menacent
dame prend g7 et elle va peut-être
pouvoir partir en a 7
mais bon il y aura dame c63 17 à voir ce
n'était pas si grave et donc ses 4
ouais quand damas ça devait arriver les
c5 peuvent tomber si la colonne des
souvenirs à damas huit matt plus
agréable pour les blancs une minute
d'avancé pour valentina tous les feux
sont au vert pour pour la joueuse russe
laurent 17 c'est intéressant pour les
blancs normalement oui mais bon mon
lalbenque et cg 6 mai à ses 4 qui tombe
bon la sphère arabe et 8 ans il n'y a
pas trop le choix plus tu remets ton roi
sur une bonne case elle perd vraiment
trop de temps sur ce genre de coup va me
prend g6 dame prend ici à yaffo à cet
échec pardon pas vu c'est ça le problème
ok dames 3 2 il faut voir ce que ça
donne quoi c'est ça le problème
mais bon elle va récupérer après h4
c'est pour ça qu'elle a pris autant de
temps
les blancs qui partent pas là dedans qui
met l'euro en b1 est ce que les noirs
vont faire les tours sète tours 8
pour la position est correct pour les
noirs le fouet si c'est fort il défend
g7 il est défendu par un g7 il attaque
h4 qui l'attaquent b2 beaucoup plus fort
que le fouet 3 je trouve au final enfin
beaucoup plus fort un peu plus fort donc
d'être les blancs intérêt à faire food
et 4 1 pour l'échangé
le flexible le fouet f6 semble faire
plus de travail que le que le fou des
quatre que le fou et 3 pour le moment
donc le mettre dans des cases pour
l'échangé semble semble intéressant
après sur food et 4 quand même regarder
dame français 4 mai à fou à cet échec
pour gagner la dame sur découverte elle
a fait pousser à auquel n'a pas dû
penser que vous des quatre était une
bonne idée mais du coup on voit vraiment
maintenant que le fouet f6 fait plus
de travail bêtement que le fou c'est un
donc rayé noir ont un petit avantage
clair et net
jd de dames 4 1 qui peuvent arriver pour
échanger les dames
et puis allez gagner un pion et après
elle aurait alors à cette finale avec
les noirs avec avantage donc prise j'ai
six prises ces quatre ça c'est sûr et il
ya la tour qui peut arriver à eux deux
une nouvelle fois conejo a dominé la
partie sur l'échiquier
mais le problème c'est qu'elle est lente
elle va encore prendre 30 secondes pour
prendre le pion et finalement elle va
repères d'une partie autant qu'elle a
dominé qu'elle mérite
là il y avait dames 2 qui était qui
était aussi possible ça attaque et la
tour et le pion ça faisait la même chose
que d'arâches 4 à pâques et le pion mais
s'attaquer la tour en plus et surtour
des deux rues d'un f1 voilà j'imagine
fouet 3 elle va partir peut-être avec du
dame b 4 c'est ce que je vous dis le
problème c'est pas d'être lente dans la
partie pour prendre l'aventage le
problème c'est qu'elle est lente même
une fois qu'elle a pris davantage
elle a pas de pointe de vitesse
tu ne peux te permettre de jouer comme
ça que lorsque tu as une pointe de
vitesse dont la valentine à qui
réfléchit des plombes
elle fait h6 alors qu' on prend h6 fou
prend h61 elle fait fouet trois
maintenant à elle évite dame b 4 comme
ça puisque ya ce gala sous pression
dames g8 trois sets c'est logique et ya
un pion de plus pour koné rouyn mai mais
je vous dis je la vois perdre une
nouvelle fois lie à aucune menace pour
les blancs dan beck a très très bien
joué et maintenant elles menacent m'as
tu en as fou c'est un va être joué et h
5 h 4 ça va partir
énorme avantage pour koné ou la lie
adams et 3 ça fait très mal
roy c1 dames b ii roi des deux
le roi qui monte à la volée elle gagne
un peu de temps elle gagne ses droits et
par parti en c1 c'était bizarre
la dame qui vient à eux qu'à talent et
un pico déroula les amis qui va qui va
faire le point l faut pas répéter trois
fois la halle est fou g5 bien joué
et on échange il va y avoir un petit
coup de tours c'est de youri dame un
math
c'était mon espoir pour mp tension quand
même ne pas perdre le pion c7 bêtement
un moment donné la dame science est sain
et voilà et voilà il n'y a pas d'âme f5
attendait ça peut encore le faire elle
se fait retourner une nouvelle fois il y
aura pas de gains c'est terrible c'est
terrible de pagaille et genre de
position pour pour albi parce que c'est
eux
parce que c'était vraiment facile à
gagner en vrai c'était vraiment facile à
gagner c'est ça ça représentait pas un
problème quelconque mais elle est pas
capable d'accélérer en vrai elle peut
pas jouer avec peu de temps sur la
pendule
c'est un défaut elle est très forte en
partie longue et c'est pas quelque chose
qui pose problème dans la vie de tous
les jours mais le truc c'est grave quand
tu arrives en bits si t'as pas la pointe
de vitesse qui peut rien tu peux dominer
le match autant que tu veux tu peux va
finir les parties tu gagneras jamais tu
ne gagneras jamais elle n'a pas la
pointe de vitesse du tout et dans
l'autre match à deux et demi deux
ennemis étonnant de voir jeanne sayari
this is how i fans comme ça on va voir
on espère quand même comme qui
reviennent je vais aller jeter un oeil
sur le temps qui reste dans cette
cadence j'imagine qu'on est à la mi
chemin mais je vais quand même jeter un
coup d'oeil
non pas que je vais jeter mon oeil 2 /
mais je vais les regarder
je vais regarder ce qui se passe que ça
dit alors donnez moi une petite seconde
à il reste onze minutes 45 quoi donc il
va lui rester deux ou trois parties
peut-être trois parties avant de passer
aux bulles est sait maintenant qu'elle
doit faire l'effort
la joueuse indienne
si elle est bonne et 2 point à la sortie
sâre est un vrai problème
comment je vais pouvoir une bonne pointe
de vitesse c'est l'entraînement mais je
vois bien jouer vite les tactiques en
fait
je vois très vite et petites tactiques
en un mois en deux enfin par rapport par
rapport à mon niveau 1 sur pareille par
rapport à maxime je suis très lent mais
par rapport aux joueurs de mon niveau je
vois vite et tactique en un certain
gagna les premières alors attends
mathieu elle est sûre d'être qualifiée
pour la finale parce qu'après une fois
que tu as fini tout ce truc des quatre
tournois et tout s'est pas encore fini
non non non non non et encore une finale
pour savoir qui gagne entre celle qui a
fini première et deuxième
toi tu es très naïve tu penses que le
tournoi de quatre semaines a duré assez
longtemps mais loin de là mathieu loin
de là il y aura encore un jour de plus
et donc à 16h à 16h30 jouera normalement
annoncer ces heures normalement il va y
avoir match de retard encore joue-t-on
élèves sarah mathieu sadate
d'après ce qu'elle travaille
exclusivement avec toi sarah sadate
exclusivement et ne travaille pas sur
tous d'accord ne travaille surtout pas
bon les noirs qui envoie une attaque un
peu pareil peste ardennes on peut pas
dire ça parce que le plomb a eu 3 mai à
lattes à calais la halle elle allait
leroy rennes jouera contre à damouzy
tout cas mon avis elle sera favorite 1
mais je vous dis tout quoi elle sera
vraiment favorite attaqué la mauvaise
ana c'est terrible
c'est terrible surtout qu'elle s'est
qualifié de justesse elle aurait dû
jouer contre moon jul donc jules qui a
dominé le match contre contre ana mais
finalement finalement sanac s'est
qualifié je pense que mon jour quand
même été plus facile mais bon anaky a
jamais très bien joué dans cet événement
voilà rejouer contre rinne accroche pour
la troisième fois mathieu
c'est terrible peut-être fou bessette
ici un crime pour attaquer la tour quand
même une certaine logique dans ce coup
après c'est peut-être mauvais hein je
sais pas il ya ya ya un truc qui peut
paraître fou mais c'était peut-être dès
qu'elle prend f5 qui traîne à un certain
moment 5 quoi qui est tombée c'est le
faucon dont on parlait maintenant que le
fouet partie de cette diagonale ton
problème 5 aidé à me ranger 4 mme piquet
de nouveaux gagnante mais comme je vous
dis elle va peut-être encore perdre
parce qu'elle est trop lente avec la
souris mais là elle fait un f4 f4 ça
faisait mal un poids avec avec le fou
qui s'ouvrait c'était terrible non elle
redonne des contres chance à les tours
fc 1 dames g5 c'est pas mal joué à
l'attack le pion et surtour ces 8es 3g
deux tours 8 par domptait 3g deux tours
c'est un tour et vii
ça c'est sûr il va falloir trouver une
idée car elle joue h6 d'abord damage 5
d'accord tours fc est maintenant il y
aura tout reprend c71 puisqu'à la tour e
8 sous menace valentina l'adage 6e pyatt
chis intermédiaires qui apporte rien
voilà il ya deux ans et sept qui tombe
elle fait tomber 5 c'est bien aussi
c'est même mieux ça évite de calculer
vos rangs tech3 f2 elle menace tout
reprend c'est cette quête domination
dans ce match d'hommes bien c'est tout
reprend ces sept là ça fait très très
mal
annonce un miracle pour pour valentina
de d'être encore à flot 1 dans ce match
et on arrive cette prise une fois
échangé les dames est la tour ans et
sept sur échec échangés en recettes
prendre prendre g7 et ce à mon avis un
petit coup de f3
ça fait pas de mal et le roi qui m'ont
et après pousser les pions ça devrait
bien se passer
hk toi j'aime bien j'ai quatre
maintenant elle se crée le pion pas ch
c'est fantastique là ce qu'elle fait
wife 4 on on se fait pas fixé et h 5h 6h
cette attention sur b2 de bien prendre
le pion et ça refait games pour pour un
petit à petit qui revient à la marque
comme pays qui dominent tellement ce
match que malgré malgré ses soucis
vraiment clair de pointe de vitesse
réussi à revenir inlassablement dans la
roue de vanina elle était menée 2 0 elle
est revenue à 2-2 elle était menée 3 2
elle revient à 3-3 elle joue vraiment
mieux que son adversaire aux échecs mais
mais allez allez allez vraiment trop
lente aussi donc le suspense le suspense
reste entier même si même si j'ai du mal
à voir un petit s'imposer dans les
bulles est
mais si elle pouvait en prendre le
devant la être à plus 1 tourne à plus 1
après peut-être que en bullet hell
pourrait faire la différence mais là
encore réflexion très longue de sa part
dès l'ouverture
ça c'est vraiment un problème qu'il
faudra régler on va laisser on va aller
jeter un oeil au score dans l'autre
match avec willy fans qui finissent par
enfin prendre les devants dans le match
3 et demi deux ans et demi on va voir
s'il a réussi à tenir l'écart c'est un
peu un peu le choc des cultures sur les
sur sur cet échiquier là en tout cas je
suis d'accord mathieu entre une joueuse
pratique rapide vanina et une joueuse
beaucoup plus forte mais peut-être
parfois trop principal be madam français
si ça paraît juste très bien cette
histoire qui a aidé cas tu peux juste
échangé ou pions prend très bien aussi
je sais pas c'est peut-être théorique et
c'est pas si con cet échange les jambes
sont là quand tu es petit rock tour b8
salaire salaire intéressant mais auquel
veut faire fou prend cavaliers prend et
mettre la pression sur le fou peut-être
le a6 était en trop
troc simplement était était possible
tout cas moi j'aime bien les noirs ici
femmes les noirs sont pas forcément
mieux mais je suis très heureux avec les
noirs d'avoir ce genre de position tu
veux tomber 8 ces cinq dames à quatre ça
se joue tout seul
vanina un peu un peu sous pression
cette fois ci elle est même pas mieux
autant vanina si elle perd cette partie
elle restera favorite du match d'après
moi parce qu'on bullet hell ou être bien
plus forte
mais ça reste compliqué quand même à 3
donc c'est pour un peu consolidé 1 le
pion à deux qu'ils pouvaient être
faibles faut être attaqué et par le fou
ou par l'adam aller ce qu'on joue la
colonne eux colin ouverte où est-ce
qu'on joue la colonne bm qui qui qui
commence par la colonne et qui va
peut-être enchaîné par la colonne b le
fou qui peut partir en d5 aussi sera
bien placé menace rouge et kateri siens
petit coup de coude et 5 peut être
intéressant
ces cinq jouer quel point 6 dame prend
1,6
ouais roi b1 pour éviter d'art à 2
j'imagine
et maintenant on va voir si elles
recentralise saddam en cinq coups en a
eu 2 même peut-être pas être une idée à
me2 pour s'en prendre aux pions f2
dameuse peut être intéressant h6 jouer
allez peut-être après tour b8 tombé six
tombes et 8
intéressant pourquoi agissent pour
éviter tous les matchs du couloir dans
un tas de variantes tu passé à jouer
pour tomber à 8
elle fait à 5 ans elle va essayer de
faire un cadre du coup et après
peut-être tombé huit tours b 6 tours b 8
elle valait fixé le pion b ça joue bien
trente secondes d'avancé pour un petit
je vais regarder le temps qui reste dans
le dans le truc il reste quarante
secondes ça pourrait être la dernière
partie de la cadence
ça pourrait être la dernière partie de
la cadence les amis ça va sûrement être
un parti de la cadence d'ailleurs ces
quatre jouer peut-être tourbe et 8 et la
dame qui pour adam 5 d'abord je vais
vous dire l adam qui pourra venir au
sein qu'on réussisse mais elle commence
par dame 5 et maintenant elle va faire
tourbe et 8 ha mais l'autre roja b3 bien
défendu sa quarante secondes chacune
allez va voir comme pays trouvent les
coûts à présent tour aussi celle de
tours 8
clairement tour des seins et d'un proche
d'eux peut-être d'un proche d'eux quand
même il faut faire bref c'est un pion ça
les amis ça se prend un pion comme ça
même si je jouais un peu étonnant g3
tour e 1
elle va jouer la première rangée dans
l'autre match juste mettre le score ya 4
2 pour 1 8 fans f4 peut-être un coup
comme tours troyes envisageable pour
essayer de rentrer dommage qu'elle n'ait
pas pris h21 tord est la même avec un
pion de plus toutes les finales serait
gagnante à les dames c'est 3 elle essaye
de rentrer par là la tour qui peuvent
venir au 1
les amis ump qui entre
de faire le taf impie m puis qui est là
à la tour tour ça fait pas grand-chose
tourbe et 8 non plus tour 2 a laissé
solide un pur pour valentina a surtout
reprendre et de ia dame prend ici
peut-être oies et fuite du coup pour
défendre non elle fait tour 3 elle
rentre elle rentre dans la gueule du
loup dame dessins qu'elle défend de
nouveau là l'atout retour un échange
échanges à savoir entrer dans une finale
de dame tour de leur tour l attaque ici
époux tout reproche de c'est maintenant
un pion de plus pour la joueuse indienne
mais malheureusement semble difficile de
faire mieux que nul ici ça peut tourner
dans un sens ou dans l'autre
parce que maintenant c'est les blancs
qui vont raser les pions elle vient
défendre son pion d'amd catch on sait
qu'elle ferait dames c'est cette dame à
5 pour aller faire la course allait tout
reprend g3 maintenant peut-être d'amd de
leur tournant tour g1 l échange et ya le
pion âge qui va partir elle fait d'alger
6 elles menacent le pion ces deux c'est
pas mal pas mal pensé et maintenant h5
dame prend à 5 h 4 elle a quand même
beaucoup d'avancé avec son pion dame g3
maintenant bien joué ou les amis h 3 h 2
h 1 il est en train de partir ce pion
les amis elle valentina qui su aller h3
allenby faut pas laisser de perpète h2
roi avance à l'est
non elle va tomber non elle va tomber
elle va tomber
ok elle a réussi après move aulas
l'avait pas tomber mais extraordinaire
de pas être tombé il y avait peut-être
perpète
elle a failli tomber dans une position
aussi gagnante que samedi
incroyable incroyable les amis impies
qui était à quelques encablures de la
chute mais qui finalement reste en selle
dans ce match elle reste bien assise sur
sa chaise elle est montée en danseuse et
elle a réussi à l'emporter elle prend
elle prend l'avantagé l'impie bien joué
mais c'était une partie vraiment
vraiment compliqué on a pensé que leurs
avants étaient proches
j'ai cru qu'elle allait tomber mais
finalement elle a elle a tenu et willy
fans voilà c'est la pause les amis on va
faire comme tout à l'heure on va se
passer la dernière partie en entier
pendant la pause et on se retrouve dans
cinq petites minutes pour le dénouement
qui sera j'ai envie de dire intéressant
au possible avec deux deux joueuses qui
s'accrochent impies qui mériterait on va
voir si elle réussit à faire parler la
poudre d'escampette à tout de suite
l'élite
à
alors les amis on est de retour le match
qui n'a pas encore repris à un piqué qui
est pas encore là mais ça ça va bientôt
bientôt reprendre
ça va très bientôt reprendre les amis
alors on va on va laisser les joueuses
se reposer encore une petite une petite
minute saveurs qui arrivé pendant la
pause on va voir un voir ce que ça donne
valentina qui doit être favorite à mon
avis je vérifier que ce soit bien la
pose de l'autre côté aussi j'aime bien
mettre le le truc officielle pendant les
pauses
à l'autre partie qui encore en jeu en
vrai d'accord j'ai vu se lever les deux
j'ai vu une des deux joueuses se lever
dans l'autre match mais en vrai il ya
une autre partie en cours désolé les
gars bon de toute façon rate pas grand
chose oui fans qui va qui va faire qui
va faire le match mais c'est pas sûr
qu'elle gagne la partie
la partie roucourt mais après la pause
va durer m'apprend à valentina est
favorite parce que parce qu'elle est
beaucoup plus forte quand il ya peu de
temps à la pendule bon dans l'autre
match
un pee wee fans pardon a pris un grand
avantage
gt gt dribbler part par une joueuse qui
était debout dans l'autre match j'étais
sûr que le match était fini elle a dû se
lever pour prendre quelque chose et je
pensais qu'elle s'est élevé puisque
c'était la pause on va voir le match le
match cas de l'inter est là les amis
vous êtes plutôt pour qui vous êtes
plutôt pour un petit ou plutôt pour pour
valentina parle d'un vraiment très mal
joué pour moi ce match je vais plutôt
pour un pied parce que j'aime bien que
les joueurs qui dominent aux échecs
guinée match
on va voir le beau jude pour un bide
autres pour valentina mais valentina
favorite elle est tellement longue tempi
que je la vois pas je la vois pas gagner
on verra j'espère me tromper
j'espère me tromper
j'espère me tromper bon attendre un que
ça reprenne pas mal de temps mort dans
cette compétition
alors on attend les joueuses allait
jouer sont debout tu pas trop quoi vous
raconter un au delà de sa compétition
est très très longue
du coup je ressens un peu un peu fait le
tour de tout sauf que ceux-ci
intéressantes d'autres matches paris à
la différence de vitesse
ah ouais bah là du coup parce qu'il est
serré mais c'est étonnant que c'est
étonnant que quel soit que le match
aussi serré en faites pas on prévoyait
que ce soit juste un massacre à cause du
temps mais en fait un homme qui a
tellement tellement tellement mieux
jouer qu'elle a réussi à être pas mal
dans le match mais en vrai ça devrait
pas être le cas et ce qu'est une battle
dimanche je voyais contre les tchèques
bras c'est quand le prochain tour avec
de l'enjeu alors il va y avoir les
olympiades sur internet a le mois
prochain
je sais pas si on peut appeler ça un
tournoi avec en jeu je dirais plutôt non
à titre perso du coup ce sera les
candidats on sait pas trop comment ça
quand ça va reprendre peut-être
valentine à penser que le match serait
trop facile le barbarian je suis
d'accord avec toi
une question me soit kiev
ça ressemble à quoi cannes l'hiver j'ai
envie d'y aller avec ma copine demande
évitant toute la jet set et la hype de
l'été ah bah bien en septembre mais il
n'y a pas dans de fa les gens pensent
que c'est hyper bling-bling berdja 7
mais en vrai nom andré ce parce que tu
penses en vrai c'est plutôt cool même
l'été le soir il ya du monde tout est
ouvert c'est sympa et le truc jet set ou
quoi moi je les vois jamais un fond
leurs soirées privées sont sur leur
bateau ils sont dans leurs soirées
privatives tu les vois pas en vrai mais
l'hiver jusqu'en septembre ou octobre
c'est cool
après
d en décembre encore ses coudes pendant
noël est un peu des trucs mais sinon
novembre janvier février mars
oubliant ses la presse c'est là c'est là
c'est la rs bon ça va être dur pour koné
roues quand même on va voir
valentina qui peut complètement assuré
sa qualif avec une victoire on va voir
si elle se réalise cette victoire oui si
elle devra encore attendre pour être
officiellement qualifiés pour la grande
finale des speechs est féminin parce que
c'est petit cagna des trucs à faire
genre musées bibliothèques n'y a pas de
musée a pas des bibliothèques info que
tu oublies un nombre de caves
non mais à deux musées qui se battent en
duel après as tu voir des musées tu peux
à la valorise pour voir le musée picasso
tu peux aller à voir tu peux aller à
nice pour le musée chagall ou ou le
musée matisse à monaco l'été a souvent
des expositions
l'année dernière j'avais vu dalli donc
tu as quelques trucs mais met clairement
évidemment c'est pas trop landreau tu
vas voir des musées quoi bon après le
musée picasso à vallauris il est sympa
le musée matisse à nice aussi chagall
s'écoule aussi tout cas quelques trucs
et coucou althea 64 ça fait tellement
longtemps qu'on t'a pas vu althea on
était en sueur pour toi et salut de
chars sornettes killer sa tête reprendre
donc juste pour vous rappeler alors dans
l'autre match le score est de 5,2
finalement oui fans qui a fait l'écart
qu'on s'attendait qu'elle ferait trois
points là ça devrait aller pour elle
donc ça a vraiment joué dans ce match où
la joueuse indienne mène d'un point
voient la région est sympa pour les
golfeurs ouais c'est vrai qu'il ya pas
mal de golf ici aussi
ouais le musée matisse il est cool à
nice après il n'est pas non plus
exceptionnel mais sympa jolie l'endroit
en fait oui fans se qualifier faut
qu'elle gagne quatrième tournoi ray
allez c'est parti les amis
valentine agouni naquit qui joue sa
place en finale face à un pic au nerf ou
avec les pièces blanches la joueuse
indienne qui va tout tenter un qui va
essayer d'accélérer le rythme de se
mettre en danseuse de se lever sur les
pédales pour pour accélérer dans cette
dernière ascension le bullet le 1 + 1 et
elle a déjà un petit retard à la pendule
à en ce début de partie
dans saab au gua indienne mais mais mais
elle va pouvoir enchaîner les coups elle
fait 3 à les fous des trois sages ou au
centre valentina qui prend immédiatement
la casse de 4 qui va peut-être se
renforcer avec du quart et les 17
cavaliers apsys ou avec du f 5 mp qui
joue dame ces deux pour chasser de
cavaliers et donc f5 c'est chose faite
maintient le cavalier en vie elle prend
quand même en d2 les blancs qui
reprennent en d2 et dames g5 menace
maths en un pas très discret mais force
quand même à faire un coup de défense
les blancs qui coupe la diagonale du fou
pia par quatre les noirs qui joue
cavalier 17 pour amener ce cavalier vers
f6 et maintenant les blancs qui vont
devoir trouver une manière efficace de
faire bouger leur centre qui va devoir
devenir mobile mais regardez déjà une
pique au nez ou qui en danger autant
qu'il ya déjà trente secondes de retard
il sait presque rien passé dans cette
partie alors que valentina comina
commence à danser avec ses pièces un
cavalier qui est venu en c5 qui s'en
prend aux fous des trois qui s'en prend
aux pions e4 elle va pouvoir prendre le
fou ça va s'échanger dame prend des
trois est peut-être à 5 pour venir
manque casser la structure blanche et
jouer sur la colonne à noël ou tours 8
aussi intéressant pour prendre
éventuellement en d5 et jouer le long de
cette colonne e cavaliers f3 attaque la
dame la dame qui bouge en g4 qui contre
attaque le pion aux quatre prise le 4 et
le 5 maintenant elle laisse le pion
prisme elles menacent eux quatre la dame
qui va récupérer le pion ça va échanger
dans ces échanges pas peut-être le
cavalier qui va revenir en d2 pour viser
cette classe de 4è tout dames 3 pour le
moment mais maintenant c'est le pion c4
qui tombe 40 secondes d'avancé quasiment
pour la joueuse russe hommes piccone
roues en grande difficulté les amis qui
ne réussit pas du tout à suivre le le
rythme de la joueuse russe qui vraiment
fait la différence dans ce dans cette
dernière portion prise à vii elle va
reprendre de la dame probablement les
blancs qui vont tenter du cavalier g5
j'imagine la dame qui va repartir vers
g6 ouvert des cinq pour faire la
synergie avec le fouet s'en prendre aux
pions g2 le pion qui vient en f3 qui
fait le petit mur h six cavaliers e4
donc remise un peu le le pion c6
peut-être la tour qui peut arriver en
ont c'est 7 pour pour un petit ours et 8
contre la colonne pris ces huit prix ces
huit dames ces trois attaques le fou fou
l5 peut-être dams et 7,1 pour s'activer
on laisse le plomb le 4 et 11 joueurs
pour des échecs non elle fait car allégé
trois fous j'ai six dames c'est cette
attaque le pion dame prend b6 maintenant
elle récupère son pion de retard piccone
roux qui revient dans l'est dans les
roues la de la joueuse russe qui vient
de de laisser filer un avantage
quasiment décisif s'est pas encore fait
les amis côté côté valentina goût nina
dans cette partie laurent h2 qui est
bien blindé et maintenant les changes
des dames et le pion b qui courent il va
courir se plomber les amis il est pas
s'éloigner le roi qui revient aux c'est
incroyable ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est incroyable pion qui parent
b5 le fou qui va devoir faire les
bordures pour revenir
le roi qui va revenir le cavalier qui va
prendre des six sur walf 7e mb cette
hausse à semble fini les amis c'est
incroyable ce qui est en train de se
passer
valentina qui aulas le pion bessette qui
a aidé cissé b 7 ans est terrible c'est
terrible c'est une pièce net de +
valentina qui devrait qui devrait
abandonner ici l faut pas qu'elles
qu'elles perdent du temps là la partie
qui dure qui dure qui dure qui dure
olalalala valentina quelle quelle
catastrophe pour elle elle n'accepte pas
la défaite mais qu'à valider 2
3 ça vient et un pic au neo qui s'impose
c'est incroyable les amis impies qui est
plus qu un demi point de la victoire
dans ce match
est-ce que valentina va réussir à faire
deux victoires ici c'est incroyable les
amis une pique contre le cours du jeu là
cette fois ci qui s'impose et qui est
complètement dans le match aller elle
est à quelques encablures de la ligne
d'arrivée et elle a lancé le sprint
valentina qui eux qui souffrent derrière
chemise ouverte elle cieux
elle sut complètement on va voir si si
elle réussit à revenir dans cette partie
en tout cas la halle avantage pour le
moment dans l'ouverture mais ces cinq
hommes piccone route nous a déjà montré
qu'elle joue assez bien ce genre de
position et impie qui en plus je joue
rapidement l ai pas trop en retard au
temps elle serre la vis la mp allez va
falloir mettre les les colonnes les
tours sur les colonnes ouverte et un pic
à une position correcte à mon avis il y
aura pas plus de trois parties dans ce
dans ce bull est la première a duré déjà
très longtemps et il va suffire d'art
match nul là pour un pis pour s'imposer
mais allez il reste déjà plus 43
secondes 59 secondes pour valentina qui
a une position correcte qui va essayer
de pousser eux 4 qui va mettre la
pression au centre un pic qui est en
train de s'endormir un pic à 1000
scaphandre monsieur qui est en train de
plonger en profondeur alors qu'il faut
être en surface les amis un petit en
manque d'oxygène dans cette danse est
parti mais qui joue b4 qui prend b4
hélas le fou peut-être va coulisser vers
la case de 1,1 de ses quatre pour
chasser cette dame aller à 5 jouer elle
donne la casse b5 mais c'est pas grave
car elle essaie de dames b6 fouet f2
peut-être tout reprend d un ici les amis
qui va qui va tomber au la case d3 aussi
qui s'allument pour pour la joueuse
indienne
olala valentina qui explose complètement
dans ce bull est incroyable la joueuse
russe qui va devoir s'en remettre au
destin de des autres joueuses peut-être
pour se qualifier en finale
le fou qui vient en c4 aller ça peut
être échangé une tour qui va arriver en
d2a ça fait mal dans le cavalier qui
vient en d3 d'abord qui attaquent f2 qui
attaquent b2 plus de 40 secondes pour la
joueuse russe mais seulement 24,1 pour
la joueuse indienne en difficulté qui va
prendre probablement le fou en f2 et
remettre un cavalier sur la case des
cinq centralisée
ou peut-être un coup comme fou bk tous
fous ces cinq mais faut se décider la
côte est impie plus 15 secondes pour la
joueuse indienne qui jouent aux cinq
finalement à tacle le cavalier qui va
repartir peut-être vers la case b3 pour
couvrir la casse des deux plus de 30
secondes pour la joueuse russe qui prend
son temps
c'est maintenant qu'il faut produire son
effort peut-être un dame bessin ku'damm
c6 intermédiaire aussi jouable elle pèse
elle pèse ses coups je pèse mes mots et
il lui reste plus que 20 secondes les
amis autsai et c'est maintenant que ça
va jouer cavalier f5 ll on voit tout sur
le roi adverse dans son style
caractéristique valentina qui barrent
qui part à l'assaut du roi noir
mais le fou qui vient b4 la tour qui va
peut-être atterrir sur la case des de la
dame h4 elle veut dames chez 5
elle veut mener une attaque éclair sur
le roi de la joueuse indienne la dame
qui arrive angers 5 elle veut peut-être
un damas six un jour un pays qui a plus
de sept secondes mais qui envoie une
tour en des deux tours c'est 8 elle veut
elle veut rentrer mais peut-être damas
si cela pour tout couvrir damphousse et
elle couvre la casse et 8 l attaque
peut-être trois dans certaines variantes
plus de sept secondes pour la joueuse
russe cavaliers h67 en échec les amis il
faut réagir là que tu aimes pays a
presque plus tant qu'ils ont aux cinq
qui tombe un pic irréfléchie impies qui
va tomber un petit qui tombe chute de la
joueuse indienne incroyable avec cinq
secondes à la pendule
c'est terrible c'est terrible les amis
de tomber comme ça c'est terrible une
nouvelle fois elle avait dominé la
partie de a à z et elle chute comme ça
hot hot ans et c'est terrible ce match
pour un pays qui joue vraiment trois
classes au-dessus de son adversaire mais
qui réussit pas à fermer le match ça va
être ça va être terrible
olaf à 3/1 fou prend des deux excusez
moi c'est héroïque
allez on va on va y aller la côte est
impie faut mettre le four b2 fois
accéléré ce serait vraiment dommage un
pur pour la joueuse indienne de rater ce
match est le mérite vraiment mais mes
valentina qui est là qui qui qui
résistent quoi qu'il en soit et qui
restent qui reste dans ce match a à un
point de son adversaire dans la dernière
partie est une nouvelle fois une pique
qui plonge qui perd autant lls ls des
secondes précieuses s'égrainer dès le
début de la partie
il va falloir ramener les tours au sens
de faire quelque chose de rapide envoyer
ses 5 à l'ompi
on croit en toi il faut il faut que tu
ailles la chercher cette partie
si tu veux aller en demi finale de la
compétition où tu on retrouvera une
autre joueuse on ne sait pas qui on
verra après les prochaines demi-finales
mais lui reste maintenant déjà plus que
26 secondes et valentina qui a mis un
coup d'accélérateur
alex valentina qui a appuyé sur le sur
le bouton turbo et valentina qui à mon
avis devrait devrait s'imposer même si
rien n'est encore fait dans cette partie
en tout cas elle y va avec beaucoup de
conviction la joueuse russe
là je me sens russe par nom est allé
assez rusé d'ailleurs elle envoie elle
envoie tout allait le roi et elle voit
que son adversaire est bien trop lente
elle va faire des 5 et f4 je vous le dis
tout de suite et elle va aller mater à
la main elle est là ça va faire très
très mal
pour koné roux qui réussit quand même à
chasser le cavalier aller faut y aller
il faut envoyer des cinq fonds envoyés
aux quatre vingt secondes pour la
joueuse indienne qui accélère qui en
prend f5 ol a pris le tour f 5 adam g 5
qui arrive une nouvelle fois elle domine
encore cette partie on croyait que
c'était fini mais elle est de nouveau là
les amis elle va prendre g5 et sur fion
prend s'est cassé la tour qui va
peut-être arriver à l'étranger 5 et
peut-être tout reprend ses quatre
maintenant avec un échec perpétuelle qui
peut tomber les amis attention d'alger
si ces jouets et échangent les dames et
prend ses 4 c'est un pion plus pour pour
la joueuse indienne dans une finale
complètement gagnante maintenant elle a
besoin que d'une nulle
mais attention au temps 18 secondes
seulement allait elle elle peut la
gagner la petite tour en d'air pour
prendre la colonne ouverte
baie saint paul ier les pions il ya les
pions noirs qui vont lui arriver dessus
il ya le pion qui va partir en c4 il
faut être hyper vigilant tour 17 ses
trois tours sète marseille change
oh là là c'est terrible le pion c'est
quasiment inarrêtable faut repartir avec
la tour les amis assez dur au la joueuse
indienne là qui se fait retourner à
contre le cours du jeu complètement
contre le cours du jeu et on prend des
quatre prises et maintenant il ya à 5 b
4 ans les pions qui partent pas aux
valentins à qui on voit pas les pions
envoie t pions le pion c3 qui tombent
les amis à 5 b 4 n'est jamais parti
c'est terrible c'était à et pour
valentina elle n'est pas parti avec les
pions elle se retrouve de nouveau mal la
partie qui a encore tourné la partie qui
a encore tourné le pion b5 qui va tomber
et là maintenant il va falloir gagner
avec les noirs cette finale deux tours
ça va être quand même très compliqué et
puis on h quatre pions h 5 ans c'est
incroyable qu'ils allaient pas envoyer
les pions là bas qu'est-ce qui sait
pas assez pour valentina tourtour g5
allez faut pas la jouer pour gagner faut
juste faire nul fait des échecs prend là
nul prend là nul pourquoi tu joues pour
gagner ta le talent matches gagnés tac à
faire annuler
t'as qu'à faire nul fait un père pète ça
sert à rien de gagner
c'est le père pète non elle joue le gars
au c'est terrible oc des images
insoutenables les amis elle est propre à
l'être prend pas le match elle prend pas
le match t'as qu'à faire perpète
mais oui elle a fait perpète elle a fait
le père pète les amis elle est allée
chercher je pense que le match est
terminé il ya plus de temps y a plus le
temps larbitre l'arbitré finit non ça
joue encore il reste encore quelques
secondes dans le match
c'est terrible au nord c'est fini c'est
fini un pays qui s'imposent
un pays qui s'imposent les amis c'était
pour valentina qui se fait éliminer un
pays qui se lève
oh là là quelle joie sur son visage elle
est heureuse elle remporte ce match les
amis c'est terrible pour valentina qui
qui aura été dominé de a à z dans ce
match et dans l'autre match du coup
victoire du oui fans assez facile assez
incroyable c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable les amis assez incroyable ce
qu'on vient de vivre
et mme pico nehru qui se qualifie face à
valentina qui devra encore attendre le
résultat de des autres joueuses pour
savoir si si elle est qualifiée pour la
grande finale du speech est féminin et
merci arasa pour le tweed prime mais
j'ai un peu mal à la gorge
officiellement c'est terrible ce match
quelle fin de match 1 les amis quelle
fin de match
quelle fin de match et amis
extraordinaire
extraordinaire donc pas demi-finales
100% russes ouais ouais et alexandra qui
va qui va souffrir un contrat rica ça va
être un match compliqué qui peut passer
devant valentina a way peut-être sera
peut-être personne en fait on essaye de
se faire rêver les gars je sais pas
exactement
j'ai regardé l'autre jour mais chez plus
puisqu'il ya russie égalité avec ou chez
nina et merci à bloc pour le switch frei
merci tonton
j'essaye de ne pas trop regarder comme
y'a pas trop d'enjeux j'essaye de me
laisser un enjeu pour moi de ne pas trop
savoir les cas de figure au moins ça te
laisse un peu rêver c'est mieux que rien
une ride tour de france ouais ouais je
suis un peu fatigué ben ouais en fait
frais qu'ils fassent des commentaires
plus éco plus je sais pas faire
malheureusement mais je gagnerai à faire
de l'éco plus
donc la peur d'avoir un jour ton temps
et c'est tellement cool dre
il faut un saab at elle commenté
entièrement comme ça a quel ouais mais
le problème c'est que pour commenter
comme ça faut que je sois seul je peux
je peux pas je peux pas commencer comme
ça quand je suis avec quelqu'un en fait
c'est pas possible
faudrait que fabriquer vraiment un
commentateur chevronnés qui puissent
qu'ils puissent suivre le rythme en fait
parce que sinon c'est dur un regard
surtout pour tes commentaires ouais ça
oui merci
il faut que tu formes femmes mais c'est
parce pas facile à faire un
c'est difficile à faire ça en fait
c'est pas facile à faire en vrai c'est
beaucoup de travail en fait pour pouvoir
faire ça c'est pas quelque chose que tu
peux faire naturellement ou quoi alors
sarah elle joue contre musi tchouk donc
attendais pas du tout bon endroit là et
merci du coa blue que pour pour l'autre
seube
on va mettre les bons noms du coup on
sait maintenant ce que veut dire le nom
de sarah en plus un mail à la hâte en
cadets mal chat rayé donc la garde de la
garde des sceaux quelque part contre ana
musi tchouk
anna zouk plein d'orthographe possible
mais je crois que son orthographe c'est
celle là avec un z aller hockey au passé
sur un stream si elle gagne pas un
problème c'est qu'elle parle pas
français
sarah la soutient à fond il faut dire on
est le plus grand supporter de sarah
quand même ça date pas d'hier qu'on la
suive
ça date pas d'hier
ça date pas d'hier - alors attends on va
la chercher mais elle sait qu'elle a
énormément de supporters ou pas à ça
vient de commencer du coup et non mais
on regarde pas du bon côté on veut
regarder du côté de ça on va suivre
sahara alors on est bon elle joue la
petite espagnole avec g6
non mais c'est sarah qui va gagner
elle sait pas à quel point elle a des
supporters imagine même pas j'ai été
contacté par un parrain de ces derniers
d'entraîneur à temps mathieu qui a hier
un truc
d'ailleurs est ce que tu veux commenter
la grande finale avec moi mathieu du
speech est féminin c'est lundi je crois
que c'est commenter la finale d'un
événement féminin sans mathieu ça fait
bizarre ça va être terrible
ça a été fabriqué sahara qui joue
j'aimerais bien savoir comment mathieu
choisi aussi les filles qui l'entraînent
vers sa menace c4 et v3 haïtien
attention hamoudi tchouk l'heure je sais
pas mathieu je peux essayer de savoir je
peux essayer de savoir alors sur ces
quatre ils devaient avoir une magouille
parce que sa menace quand même b3 alors
dit quoi il fout des quatre je te fais
f6 d'accord karvelis c'est un chef et b3
et prend b3 assez prend b3 dame prend b3
et tu te dis que les blancs sont mieux
bon faut quand même faire gaffe à l a
fait c 4 elle n'a pas du tout vue
extraordinaire si on prend s'éprendra me
prend et ça gagne
et merci à ben look pour pour le solde
des effets match à 21 ans joue contre
eux qui à 20 heures d'aidé bayer jupp
heynckes de plus pour sarah c'est
terrible c'est terrible pour al amoudi
tchouk dia complètement future with each
look tout en sourire musique soutenant
option qui est tout le temps en train de
sourire contre marquant c'est quoi ce
match mathieu c'est bizarre comme match
c'est terrible c'est terrible dames 6
peut-être tour c'est 8 à les attaques à
la tacle cavaliers
mais peut-être un petit caillou c'est 5
pour revenir en jeu voilà c'est juste
une pièce de plus un pour sarah qui
devrait qui devrait l'emporter un jet
pack elle a rallié la finale
j'ai essayé de savoir j'essaie de savoir
en tout cas le match qui débute bien
pour moi les grandes favorites du match
ça
déjà en début de match et un peu vu les
matchs de musi choo qu'elle me paraît
pas super fort dans ces matches là non
plus à sarah qui commence avec une bonne
partie mathieu qui nous lâchent pas d'un
faux c'est terrible c'est incroyable
donc key c5 et merci du coup pour le
train de la hype donc qui est prend le
cas dans la partie avait complètement
foutu pour port anna je sais pas je sais
pas trop pourquoi elle continue mais
difficile de rentrer dans un match comme
ça phil est une pièce direct ça devrait
permettre
ala joueuses iraniennes de prendre
l'aventage quoi que tu reprends des six
bons tours c'est 6 1 et n'en parle plus
ouais mathurin côté mystérieux
exactement très mystérieux mathieu tout
une toute une nappe de mystère qui
entoure cet homme ont tout reprend à 6
tours prend 1,4 ça se gagne tous seuls
sept wassat ici avant de s'embêter 5 qui
est des 5e et 6e prendra 4
h5 ça évite les tourbains tomber cette
tour prend qui prend 1,4 à avoir le pion
la récupère les pions maintenant tour à
six cavaliers c5
ça va gagner tout seul
alors comment est ce qu'elle veut
arnaquer ça la ne pas prendre air
revient que le roi et la reine
lecavalier est un acquis abandonne bon
c'était déjà 1-0 partie pas très
intéressante un pièce de plus direct on
va voir ce que ce cas là nous propose
avec les noirs en espérant que ce soit
mieux puisqu'elle nous a proposé avec
les blancs échanges a peut-être faire
aux trois des quatre
ouais participa travail intéressant doit
non mes trucs c'est une pièce de plus la
partie a duré cinq minutes et il s'est
rien passé quoi sert à que si elle gagne
le tournoi peut peut se qualifier pour
la finale encore assez extraordinaire
les prépas savant quel pourcentage le
temps d'un joueur pro vous pensez tués
hier dans l'entraînement sûrement 90%
c'est énorme
ouais non mais c'est énorme c'est
quasiment que des prépas après bombay 6
c'est à dire un cavalier à 4 pour
échanger ou des cadets 4 c'est dur a
claqué cette fois ci se fout des trois
ici peut être une option
cavalli b4 même pire pour jouer la case
d3 qui a et b 4 semblait encore plus
fort salut c'est tellement la case d3 à
3 l empêche quelque part à l'arrivée du
cavalier alors attaqué et b4 ana
bon le problème c'est que le pion des
deux est bloqué mais tant que c'est pas
un cavalier sur cette carte glace pas
trop grave
quebéc à tulle et c'est pas des quatre
parce que sur des cats et qui a aidé 3
j'essaie de faire aimer les échecs un
ami il me dit ça me paraissait nul comme
game quand tu sais que les meilleurs
apprennent par coeur les patterns c'est
un jeu qui récompense la meilleure
mémoire et son accès en gros le maire
dictionnaire et humain tu réponds à quoi
ça il raconte n'importe quoi en fait
juste il a jamais dû jouer donc moi je
galère un peu avec les flèches
bon c'est pas
c'est pas clair encore fort en d3 est
bien placé mais pas sûr que ça suffise
pour un avantage non mais même à 2500
plus cher en être killer enfin la selphy
là et on a pas mal sur les 2500 plus et
tu m'aimes veulent en face même sans
trop connaître de théorie les défonce
même s'ils utilisaient pas trop de
théorie les plus forts même beaucoup
plus fort
tu vois bien que magnus en rapide même
si je joue ça il va quasiment tout le
monde bon alors c'est complètement
ridicule avec les noirs donc c'est pas
du tout un jeu que de mémoire après
c'est ça qui fait la différence entre
les meilleures conditions au même niveau
mais à
c'est comme dire je sais pas ce que psy
au tennis c'est que le service qui fait
la différence mois peut-être un certain
niveau quand tout le monde est super
fort servir un peu plus fort c'est un
gros avantage mais bon ouais sahara qui
est bien de nouveau ce qu'elle va
commencer à pouvoir faire jouer le
déséquilibre avec le fou g2 qui est bien
à la qui est dans le dur mais voilà tout
en l'air heureuse ana c'est marrant quoi
à la tarn son cas est tout le temps en
semi sourire et sarah semi blasé tout le
temps quoi marc en secret son visage
complètement différente
bon
donc ça échange des trois mois elle va
jouer le fou g2 qui va être supérieur
peut-être cahier décati si intéressant
d'ailleurs pour libérer le fou elle a
été très mal je pense sahara si elle
faisait qui a et b 4 tout à l'heure à
nages crois que c'était game 1 c'était
quasi finie mais l'a pas fait et du cou
et du coup elle est bien même très bien
on va voir c'est un crack comme twitter
quand j'y repense à la finale de
valentina goût nina qui a pas fait à 5
b4 attendait 6 dames c3 et des quelques
années des 4o toujours sa fin ça a l'air
de faire malin ce qui est des 4
on va voir
mais bon ce pas une fin en soi fire sap
a gagné la partie mais quand ce faisant
rayonner ça va faire mal j'ai juste
regardé les scores des deux l'autre
match avec alexandra qui a déjà pris de
l'avancé sur arica qu'il a pris à partie
mais quand même favorite alexandra et
juste pour dire pour dans les
demi-finales alexandra qui affrontera en
plus qu'au nez rouge je pense
qu'alexandre a va faire très très mal un
petit koné roues donc alexandra qui
pourraient aller déjà en finale 1 et
ouais non ça va être chaud ça va être
très très chaud caillé des quatre jouer
car il est prend des 4 et peut-être vous
prend à 8 du coût pour ces 8 va être
jouée qui a éprouvé 5 et ça a l'air
d'être très cool pour les blancs c'est
un pion de plus ça a l'air d'être très
sympa pour ça on va voir comment ça
évolue
on va voir là donc à elle jouera en
demi-finale
willy fans ce peut être un beau match
pourri fans qui à mon avis un peu au
dessus on verra
qui prend b5 peut-être faire un petit
coup deux à quatre pour défendre le
cavalier ainsi sûrement et quelque chose
comme damas un tour c'est un pour
chasser la dame
moi j'ai huit tours c1 dames b4 tomber m
dames ses seins il va falloir réussir à
bouger le cavalier quand même temps 1 mt
4 c'est quoi le truc tour b1 à b5 d'un à
trois et protège la tour et cavaliers
prend à 3 ans cadets change donc ouais
parti qui semble vraiment bien se
dérouler pour pour sarah qui blâment un
an peut prendre
apprenant des 101,5 prises cinq prises
ces huit prises ces huit prises à 6
tours c'est un fouet fin mai suit droit
g2
ça a l'air de bien se passer quand même
pour la joueuse iranienne on va voir
comment ça se termine tout cas il ya un
pion de plus dans la finale il va
falloir la gagner et tour c'est un tour
c5 maintenant et surtout ses 8 peut-être
cavalia sera fait qu'à ibb et 5 pour des
huit bons bien aussi il va falloir la
gagner et en échangeant les pions est-ce
que c'est gagnant c'est un quatre contre
trois et que les tours carrées les
contours cavaliers ça va être difficile
ça doit être nul ça mais bon ça va jouer
pendant longtemps mais dommage de
laisser passer cet opus est occasion
pour eux pour sarah
alors anna qui votent contre attaquer
sur des deux intéressants la majorité
des gens ne suffit pas non 4 contre 3
généralement c'est nul mais bon avec les
cavaliers ça donne un peu de paix y
avoir des fourchettes peut y avoir des
trucs
voilà l échange ça va être complètement
nulle maintenant ça ça va être
complètement nul les amis je vois pas
dans quel monde ça peut gagner
sarah qui laisse quand même passé une
grosse chance ça va jouer pendant
longtemps par contre j'ai quatre héros
f5 val a réussi à répéter les coûts
rapidement anna qui sauve qui sauve le
demi point ici très bonne opération pour
elle qui réussi à rester dans le match a
pas se faire braquer garde un point
d'écart et elle peut elle peut
psychologiquement se sentir plutôt
heureuse puisqu'elle revient elle
revient d'un passage très très compliqué
alors il reste combien de temps à la
carence aux nues donc il doit y avoir
encore de partir dans cette cadence
notre un pied vanina qui a guéri c'est
finalement un mp 1 qui a gagné à la
surprise générale semblait tellement
moins forte en en bullet que c'est très
surprenant qu'ils allaient gagner mais
elle a réussi à le faire
bon alors là on a cette petite heure
espagnole des changes spécialité de mazo
des cats a échangé mais maintenant elle
va attaquer le fou aussi ce qu'est ce
que va faire ana on va voir je vais
aller ouvrir la fenêtre les amis fait il
fait un peu chaud là une petite seconde
à la dédoubler les pions à de sarah may
mais le roi de sarah pourrait pour être
faible
je veux ouvrir la fête
histoire d'avoir un petit peu d'air ou
c5 elle s'active prises six logiques
prises elle va reprendre du cavalier on
ne peut pas faire flouer trois mètres de
fond f40 du coup et préparer tour c'est
un pour taper sur le pion c7
il fait chaud dont le suédois est là
aujourd'hui là il fait chaud là j'ai un
petit coup de chaud là tu respires pour
que tu existes non mais il ya plus d'air
du tout en fait fougueux 3 alors sur
dame prend 1,4 à vouloir tour c1 et
accélérer le jeu ça je vais mettre le
redis pour voir à le faire crisser trois
dames cette dame j'ai quatre arrêts
c'est tout un programme en fait ok bien
vu nous faut prendre trois dames prendre
trois baies vitrées et c3 qui avait lieu
cette tour des 1 tour 8
ok position assez égal 1
position assez égale dame g3 et met la
pression sur g7 et sur ces sept un juge
jeter un oeil au score dans l'autre
match il ya toujours un zéro dont sûr
pas finie la deuxième partie ça donne
envie de jeter un coup d'oeil quand même
ça donne envie de jeter un coup d'oeil à
leur finale
ouais alors c'est plutôt à arica qui est
qui et mieux avec le camaïeu f4
surpuissant face aux fous qui tape dans
le vide
on va voir si elles l'emportent mais
elles n'ont joué et dont je n'ai qu'une
partie leurs parties durent beaucoup
plus longtemps que celles de sarrail et
anna
bon h3 pour pour donner une case au roi
et ses 8 elle veut repartir vers des six
pour attaquer le 4 cette dame g4 ici
pour essayer d'échanger consolidé monter
le roi et saluer leur tige essai salut à
toi donc je rappelle que demain c'est
pas moi qui commenterait incera andrea
et fable donc n'hésitez pas à venir à
passer leur dire bonjour moi je me
reposerai demain
en quelque sorte qu'ils aient mieux agir
et personnes donc et ses huit dames g4s
assurant être joués jugement mettrait
pas garder les dames qui a aidé 5 et 10
6 à 7m peau
à devoir passer en courant devant
contador on verra lâche un petit peu on
l'a fait pendant un petit moment là tout
à l'heure mais en fait c'est trop long a
commenté tu peux pas bien commenter
quelque chose pendant 3 pendant quatre
heures tous les jours en fait c'est pas
possible ça existe dans aucun dans rien
en fait
dames provoqua je pense qu'elle veut
prendre ses 7 et sur ses 6 kgs c3 mais a
échoué le clouage alors parti un peu
insipide ouais ben maintenant avec un
tellement beau match juste avant que la
du coup et ça retombe un peu en pression
quoi c'est ça le truc on va voir ça
peut-être revenir petit à petit mais
mais là c'est ça retombe forcément
pression donc prise de kadior dame
française c'est bizarre de laisser dame
france s est quand même j'ai une
favorite va je pense sarah favorite mais
on va voir
peut-être quebéc arrête ici quand ça
veulent en venir ans et 6 avec la tour
avec lecavalier
j'aime pas trop les noirs perso
après avoir choses peuvent se passer un
donc et b4 jouer
les tours c'est 6 3 6 qui menacent
câlins
stein
d'accord dernier 5 l attaque le pion
mais à tatev 3 du coup chasse le
cavalier ça va arriver sur le roi ça me
parait hyper dangereux d'un bep si
c'était peut-être une option plus
intéressante way après l'état des
problèmes avec des échanges avec 3 et
carré des cinq pieds poings f6 qui
arrivait pour répondre au chat dont abc
c'est sûrement le problème un prise
prise f3 car elle bouge à peut-être car
elle la quête des cinq à la féclaz et c6
direct touch n'a pas pris et dames b6
arriver là maintenant il ya d'incroyable
deux prises f2 prises à deux est pressée
si ça l a oublié ce terrible
as eu roi prend f2 elle veut puis on
prend ces six tours pensée 6 et attaqué
deux pions mais le problème sur walf
d'oeil à tour ses huit sahel a raté à
ces terribles ses terrines de la rate et
ours et 8 mai c'est dommage parfait
juste f3
c'est terrible
on va voir
ce qu'elle va faire mais du coup ça veut
dire que sarah va sûrement emporté la
partie est et faire l'écart donc c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle mais pour les
supporters de sarah mais après c'est une
belle une belle partie une belle combine
juste mal calculé
peut-être tentés tour un meilleur arrive
cinq cas alice c3 cet échange est monté
droit
c'est l'idée mais j'ai eu droit à ses 7
et un coût puisque le roi noir comme ça
va arriver en premier
g4 jouer de casser le pion à essayer de
faire tour f 1 après
donc comment ça va comment ça peut se
continuer les noirs tu as essayé de
monter leur roi peut-être jusqu'en d65
roigé 2 3 5 3 f3 peut-être donc elle
fait tour 5 a sûrement faire tourner un
échec
kalou plus vitales à sanaa moi aussi ça
peut-être prendre cinq reprises f5 qui
prend aux 4 c'était surtout reprend
airways 3 commencé sa partie contre ea
sports déjà ya des caméras et des
surveillances puis après il suffit de
voir le niveau de jeu là ça semble clair
et net
bref trois ça peut-être tour huit tours
aux cinq as high a réussi à faire une
double attaque récupérer le pion s
harrakia pas tu auras pas montré une
énorme technique 1 dans ces finales qui
va re concédé une nulle
cela n'empêche pas mal barrés je défends
les joueuses vous demandez qu'on ne sait
si ça triche pas je regarde les parties
quoi logique
bon c'est complètement nul soit si sarah
répéter je pense pas que sarah si sarah
qui donne tout quand même
elle se bat à fond c'est peut-être la
dernière partie de la cadence d'ailleurs
ce que j'ai l'impression que elle veut
tenter bien joué elle voulait tenter le
piège 3g 4g 3ème tête prend b3 été plus
discret
bref trois rois g2 et ça va faire nul 1
1 qui a fait beaucoup de sauvetage lancé
le deuxième mais là ça échange et ça
c'est nul tranquille dans ce qui doit
être la dernière partie de la cadence on
va regarder le score des autres matches
on va se faire une petite pause qui va
me permettre de récupérer qu'au seuil ou
qui mène 2-1 et sarah qui mène 2 1
je vous repassez la partie précédente en
donc qui est comme tout à l'heure et on
se retrouve dans trois petites minutes
merci de rester là et a tout de suite à
tous les gars et je vous envoie une
petite pub au passage pour ça que vous
voyez rester une petite seconde
mais la pub qui va partir allez c'est
parti
à
les amis je suis de retour
sarah vendanger way and a sauvé vous
pouvez le prendre dans le sens que vous
voulez en tout cas le résultat est le
même
il ya qu'un point d'écart entre les deux
joueuses entre les deux femmes est donc
qu'est ce qui t'a qu'est ce qui s'est
passé à altea comment ça se fait qu'on
t'a plu vue pendant tout ce temps ça
allait me tâte tu t'es un peu lassé des
échecs où tu avais savate à pat a pas eu
de souci dans ton boulot ou quoi ce
qu'on t'a pas vu pendant pendant
peut-être deux trois mois je dirais non
ça fait plaisir de te revoir par ici
ou alors peut-être tu chat et pas
simplement au 6 1
anaky a bien défendu et c'est vrai
donc
karine f3c 5 c 4 cavaliers sait si c'est
nouveau une anglaise elle envoie des
quatre rapidement sa resteront des géo
troisième ques a fait mal mais elle
travaille vraiment jamais mathieu elles
font vraiment rien oula ça c'est la
variante hyper compliqué ou l'a7 vers
l'enclavé ya plein de trucs de partout
non pas c'est particulier de moi bien
comme il faut je pense juste à lui
commander tout y est parrain de mesures
ben écoute ce plaisir tout en soit sorti
un ep france et 4,6 cette variante là on
avait vu une partie en direct je pense
et avec mathieu en plus mais je vous
rappelle plus qui m'a ya une tonne de
théorie là dedans c'était pas pendant
les candidats nepomniachi guéri
peut-être c'est rare mais j'ai déjà vu
en tout cas j'en ai déjà parlé avec
quelqu'un en commentaire oui là c'est no
kill mais c'est le même le même début de
ce truc compliqué de fou quoi et c'était
toi tu vois j'ai une bonne mémoire quand
même je rappelle pas des coups précis
parce que je suis en train de commenter
en même temps et j'ai pas le le cerveau
qui enregistre mais je me rappelle de
loin mais je tenais peau guiry c'est
bien ça tue quand même pas trop de
conneries parce qu'en fait quand tu
commentes quand tu t'occupes de la
technique et ou de loin comme alain rey
dans ce cas ça fait plaisir de venir
voir les tontons un petit peu ouais bah
écoute n'hésitent pas à passer le soir
sur la maison mère un peut-être dam des
quatre ici padam des quatre ça me
paraîtrait logique pour essayer de
mettre le four angers 5 après tout cas
sarah qui réfléchit
inquiet qui pensent à 3 plus tôt
du coup sahara qui joue à trois aussi
fou prend cavaliers prend et rock
sûrement fait rien de toi pour voir une
vraie idée de son et l'autre que tu fais
comme à deux ou trois natures ton pion à
weight a toujours été toujours simple
quoi qu'il en soit alors merci altéad
est resté seul malgré terreur passage 4
est peut-être jouer pour eux cinq têtes
jouer pour fou j'ai 55 pas tout de suite
je vais peut-être f4 5,7 pc jouer pour
dams et de b3 four b2 aussi cette dame
de tournai un fouet f4 tour c'est à pas
mal de placements de pièces possibles
oui coopération inter milan ac est un
pion de moi j'ai oublié de le signaler
mais mais il ya énormément de
compensation et tu peux mettre la tour
en d1 tu peux être le fourrage et 5
latour ans et un f4 5 comme je disais il
ya plein de possibilités
un tour d un risque des cas de prise des
4b 5b 3 et on peut récupérer le pion des
six ces genres de variantes qui pourrait
arriver ce genre de vente qui pourrait
arriver mais sur b3 y aurait cavaliers à
5 contre attaquer le pion b3 donc pas
sûr qu elle est à 5h attaque et b3
tomber un qui est ici si sûrement
possible en tout cas car il ya eu cinq
coups fouet trois peut-être direct car
elle est à 4 j'aime bien aussi
elle attaque le pion pour le défendre
fort à faire car aliev 17 le fou qui va
venir en f4 et les tours qui vont se
placer sur les colonnes c et d et les
blancs qui vont forcément récupérer
leurs pions du rhin pour les noirs cette
position il va falloir réussir à rendre
le pion de la manière là la meilleure
possible
c'est ce qu'elle fait d'ailleurs fou 17
elle veut car il prend ses 5 pouces et 6
elle se sépare de son clown plus mais
elle sera organisée les blancs vont
garder les avantages de la paire de fou
mais y'a plus de 43 secondes pour sarah
du refus f4 jouer s'en prend aux
cavaliers car il est ici ça peut être
faire pousser cette pour repasser
éventuellement vers b6 à fait fou des
six tours des 8 ou ses huit tours une
tour hanouna n'ont en effet pas la tour
à dubaï mais la tour en des 8,5 ça
apprendre j'ai deux intermédiaires et
mettre le maîtres le cavalier sur des
cinq ont beaucoup de temps pour ce coup
franc j'ai 2 qui est des cinqs paraît
logique à fait calées g4
ah parce qu'elle veut plus ou pas ce
qu'il y'a juste sourire d'ailleurs y
accueille prend bessette aussi à y avait
4 ans baissaient dans la ligne de tout à
l'heure désolé les gars je suis un peu
de jeu fait quelques petites fautes de
calcul qui a valu à prendre 5 et tour
des cinq owassa ces classes quand même
le petit sac fils de pièces pour pour
faire la double attaque c'est très sympa
ça c'est les coups que j'aime bien ça
c'est les séquences tactique que
j'admire l'accueil prochain qui
accueillent ces 7 mai avait peut-être
cavaliers f3 contre échec c'était chaud
et maintenant la finale elle donne quoi
il ya égalité matérielle mais sarah
sadate et le pion à passer éloignés je
préfère largement les blancs mais c'est
loin d'être gagné 1
c'est loin d'être gagné mais le cavalier
c5 et puis on a cinq c'est tellement
dominant pion qui va partir à 6 à un
moment donné elle veut partir en a mais
à la tour qui vient dé 7,3 bsf six tours
ici ouais c'est chou allait peut-être
cavaliers waka et des 6es à l'attaqué
mais tour c'est cette maintenant carioca
t'échange est ce que c'est une bonne
idée ya ça a l'air d'être sympa et
peut-être c5 qui était cool oui
maintenant il ya trois des quatre et
trois c5 et c'est gagné
voilà c'est gagner facile même wes araki
qui prend ça et qui fait le break bien
jouer la part de sarah flegmatique 1 on
voit sur pas la même en moins dans
l'expression sur son visage comme d'hab
une asphyxie kevin je profite d'être là
pour te remercier pour des parties fines
à olic sur youtube j'ai pas mal
progressé grâce à sa ba écoute c'est
super un vrai bonne partie la blague la
dernière partie a vraiment été
intéressante et bien joué
alors ça va repartir dans ses repas pas
pour la même
c'est celle-là même par exemple que tout
à l'heure mais jouer différemment à et
surtout prend b2 elle me fous des quatre
fous prend un fou crois et je veux les
cases noires pour une 2 pour une bonne
partie faux de deux joueuses qui jouent
bien et ça a été le cas
les deux joueuses ont bien joué
enfin à faire d'emprunt des quatre
hockey prend
et blanc qui vont devoir continuer à
tailler des deux maintenant tour c'est
un s'en prendre aux cavaliers foulée
cette attaque le pion aux quatre tours
ans elle défend va falloir être vigilant
avec les noirs sur les cases noires
proche du roi mais il ya plus de fous de
cases noires pour les blancs donc c'est
moins grave
il ya le fou ados aussi un peu pénible
l'évaluation de l'ordi est correct mais
je préfère largement jouer ça avec les
blancs perso j'ai l'impression que les
coûts sont plus claires l'agent e5 f4
écossaise style avec f5 qui arrivait et
la marée pions ouais c'est bien joué à
eux quatre prises et ça va enchaîner
alors peut-être à fiat f 5 à 5 avec les
blancs la dame qui va repartir en a 7
j'imagine pas dame prend 1,5 même si
c'est jouable
peut-être des fous prend des cinq mêmes
ça a l'air d'aller tellement vite côté
blanc elle repart en des 8
ben ça partirait kf4 non jeu direct non
mais lecavalier en f3 elle prépare
peut-être d'amd de damages 6 pour ces
huit têtes d'amd 2 l à fait eu six a
bien joué aussi elle affaiblit droit
voilà sahara qui est dans le dur hein
les amis c'est vraiment compliqué là
pour sarah qui est vraiment sous la
pression de dana peut-être f 6 1 pour
essayer de colmater ce qu'elle peut sur
cases noires le reste paraît tellement
compromis ça paraît vraiment très
compromis là pourra pour la joueuse
iranienne sarah qui peut qui peut se
faire remonter au score 1-1 aurait plus
qu'un point de départ et tout serait
possible de nouveau pour anna qui
hésitent avec tout reprend aussi si on
prend aussi ce qui est propice pour pour
prendre la fuite mais quelles
propositions progressistes on prend
aussi semble quand même plus logique
avec une tour bien placé qui pourrait
même naviguer vers b6 pour aller
encaisser le pion b4 elle fait cavaler
des quatre bons pour faire cuire et les
prends aussi c'est aussi très logique et
les noirs qui semble vraiment dans une
position compliquée elle prend le pion à
naka reprend aussi ce parieur pas de fou
prend des cinq échecs problématique
parce que la dame pourrait reprendre en
d5 mais cependant la position est super
dur là on imagine qu'ils avaient g5
non mais c'est une dame qui peut jaillir
angers 4 ça semble ça semble compliqué
pour la joueuse iranienne qui reste
impassible en cependant elle est
toujours impassible sarah bon anna qui
prend peut-être un peu trop de temps
elle fait qualifier cinq tours g7 ses
tempos c'était fort c'est peut-être dame
g4
mais ya pas de n'y a pas de coups
gagnants elle fait d'amd 4 alors elle
prépare quoi bon elle se place à la
tacle à l attaque là elle garde un oeil
là-dessus
elle fait pas mal de choses cavaliers 5
va sûrement partir en rêve 6 avec la
dame pour aller chercher des menaces
entre guillemets ouais c'est chose faite
sarah qui a intérêt peut-être à bouger
saddam maintenant ou pas ouais là mais
on sait 5 alors un ondam 6 faut regarder
ce que ça donne
si le roi parents à schwyz ura cavaliers
f7 donc le roi devra partir en ait fui
tu es après roy et fuite on voit pas de
suite forcément alors elle fait cavalier
peut 6 elle menace de prendre et d'anne
decis maman sarah qui effectuera un
clouage c'est bien joué elle a réussi à
se recroquevillait tour f7 la matière
par angers 5
allez il reste plus beaucoup de temps
pour les deux femmes cavaliers 4 le
retour ça va changer en e1 sa déviera la
tour du vis-à-vis
maintenant il ya peut-être la tour qui
peut rentrer en russie ce donc cavalier
g7 jouer cavalier détroit donc pour
viser le cavalier de 5 à la rate et qui
prend des 5 avec la dame qui
latéralement attaqué le pion ça va
sûrement échangeant arrive si c'est ou
recettes non dames 3e garde les dames
cavaliers f5 d'am-dam c5 sûrement pour
récupérer éventuellement le pion b 4
cavaliers h4 maintenant peut-être fou
prend des 5 1 qui peut tomber elle le
fait pas alors il ya des queyries projet
de peut-être pas encore mais ça va
arriver là elles menacent maintenant
matin j'ai trois cavalières 3 et gagne
la qualité elle a fait tourner la partie
sarah et anna qui à mon avis a raté une
multitude de fou prend des 5 1 qui
permettait vraiment d'ouvrir le roi et
de refaire jouer ce fou aller il va
falloir résister encore côté côté
ukrainien s'est pas fait un cavalier qui
est bien placé il ya les cavaliers qui
rhodia qui prend des cinq aux siens
l'aura vraiment jamais pris ce pion
c'est incroyable elle veut pas le
prendre
ça y est enfin elle le prend et elle a
maintenant un pion pour la qualité
presque plus de temps côté sarah mais
mesdames tour c'est quand même un joli
duo contre contre une dame est un
cavalier c'est dur de s'organiser avec
le dame cavaliers là il ya tour 17
peut-être non l échange les dames il
faudrait récupérer à 6 pour faire un nul
elle va y arriver focus il cavaliere
revient après la position sera nulle la
cavale y aussi ces chèques cavaliers f4
elle n'y arrive pas elle part pour
cavaliers b 4 cavaliers detroit la
cavalier ses 500 cavaliers b4 qu'avec
des cinq cavaliers ou 3 way est là dans
ces cas là c'est nul théorique
ça c'est un truc à savoir pions sur la
même elle s'il ya un pion - om elle
tombe c'est terrible la qui avaient des
trois-quarts relief 4 cellules faciles
ouais donc sarah sahara qui mène
maintenant 4 k jaws à est qui qui fait
vraiment l'écart voilà il ya vraiment
vraiment une
une grosse différence dans ces matches
trois points on sait que c'est dur à
remonter il ya que trois bulles est donc
il n'y a plus vraiment de droit à
l'erreur pour musique zouk qui est quand
même dominé dans les positions
compliquées sahara qui est plus fort
tactiquement que son adversaire comme
prévu en avant match la joueuse
iranienne fait parler la poudre et elle
rencontrera donc si elle gagne ou ifan
demain dans une demi finale choc car
entre les deux femmes
alors que alexandra kosteniuk est en
train de donner une leçon arikat grenat
valley et pourra demain aller chercher
une finale si elle bat m puis koné où
aller on retombe
on retourne sur le match avec une nana
en grande difficulté 1 en grande
difficulté à les mener 2-0 dans cette
cadence 3 plus ça tu vas aller jeter un
oeil sur le temps le temps restant à
jouer pour voir si si elle peut encore
bien remonté il reste encore deux voire
même trois parties dans la cadence donc
aller elle est encore en course mais il
va falloir commencer à mal à mettre les
points à la côte est côté ukrainien
sinon le score pourrait enfler de
manière assez sale et la victoire
pourrait pourrait tendre les bras à
sarah toujours aussi un passé
bhl nawel à la belle a eu du mal à se
qualifier déjà contre moon jul après la
toujours l'air très heureuse 1 c'est un
peu l'un verse 2 sarasar a toujours
l'air un peu blasé anne a toujours l'air
heureuse quoi qu'il en soit jean pensons
qu'elle sourit plus ou moins
naturellement marrant mais tout en train
de l étouffée en train de sourire non
mais les foules sourire c'est incroyable
mais les foules sourire quant à lui la
dareta du ton alors dimanche dernier des
dernières étapes dernier pas finale du
goût des grands prix et lundi la grande
finale de tous les grands prix
alors dame b 4
elle vient se placer avec ses pièces
anna cas il prend 17 prises 17
on va voir comment ça enchaîne prix c6
prix c6 prix c6 peut-être aller prendre
le pion mais le pion décade va être
faible et le pion b2 emprise aussi elles
seront bien lundi elles seront plus que
deux lundi je pense que les noirs les
blancs sont mal en fait parce que le roi
est ouvert et si le pion d'hécatombe ça
peut faire très mal au roi la dame
français 3 serait une grosse erreur et
évidemment il y aurait bbb prend mais
damas quatre menaces la tour d un menace
le pion à deux menaces le pion des
quatre menaces un peu la tour c 6 même
si elle est protégée car b3 dame prend à
deux mais anna qui pourraient recoller
un petit peu un match assez serré dans
le dans le contenu je pense qu'elle va
prendre à deux
je pense 1 je pense qu'elle va apprendre
à 2 et se garder des quatre sous le
coude
c'est logique parce qu'elle à égalité
matérielle maintenant et encore le pion
des quatre en l'air damas six à une
petite dame b 6 h 5
elle prend de l'espace c'est bien joué
dames 17è sur place hier je regarde les
résultats des quatre gp donc chaque
fille ne fait que trois gp c'est bien ça
ouais c'est ça notre dame des sept
voir ce qui se passe maintenant je pense
qu'elle va faire hk toi c'est bien joué
elle veut faire h3 et à mettre la dame
en g2 éventuellement elle est en train
de faire de faire l'écart dans cette
partie heijmans ondam f3 il ya tout qui
rentre regardez les pions c'est terrible
c'est terrible bam prend f4 de nouveau à
égalité matérielle et là en plus le
problème c'est que tu pourras pas
prendre six parce qu'il ya encore cloué
au nom elle donne la dame en ont haussé
terrible oh c'est terrible oh c'est
terrible ouais je pense que le match se
termine là dessus les amis des seins
qu'elle faisait juste d'un même si c'est
eux et ça gagner des images
insoutenables way est là la dame qui
tombe et ça va ça va clôturer le match
ça va clôturer le match parce que là
quatre points d'écart je ne vois pas du
tout remonté et dans l'autre dans
l'autre rencontre du coup rien l'autre
on compte kosteniuk en plus en bulles
est très forte mais c'est dommage pour
l'intérêt sportif du match la dame qui
tombe sur une attaque latéral serré ce
match sympa mais tu crois pas si bien
dire le premier match était très sympa à
suivant premier match j'étais vraiment
intéressant un salut sahara non mais je
pense pas interview de sarah infligé pas
ils parlent pas français
enfin un fou en plus j'ai même pas le
temps j'ai un meeting à 18 heures je
vais vous dire c'est peut-être si elle
gagne le ton à dimanche mais eux mais je
crois je crois pas enfin
mais c'est terrible en tête si elle
gagne la finale et qu'elle se qualifie
mais la tue pas on va pas attendre 20
minutes truc à faire des trucs à faire
mais on dimanche salle yann le tournant
interview way celle se qualifiant en
finale interview mais là non là en plus
en vrai j'ai jugé juste physiquement pas
le temps en fait c'est quoi l'enjeu du
speech s j'ai envie de te dire aucun
savoir qui gagne donc un lieu 6
il gagnera pas si elle va gagner mathieu
moi je pense qu'elle peut gagner façon
elle va elle va jouer qui en demies en
demie elle va jouer ou ouais c'est chaud
parce qu'en fait elle est dans le
mauvais état tableau il aurait fallu
qu'elle soit dans le tableau où elle
joue koné roues et du coup il ya eu deux
des chances clair ce que je pense qu'on
contre conejo elle aurait gagné mais la
contre où c'est dur
ouais ça s'était pas très bien passé
déjà tout à l'heure mais bon elle a fait
l'écart quand même il ya deux points 2
il ya quatre points d'écart
avec l'autre où elles peuvent ouais mais
où elle est pas aussi forte que ça sur
internet 1 elle peut elle peut faire
quelque chose qui est des cinq filles
web enfin fini fini kf5 a contracté la
dame l affaire d'âme e71 je vois pas où
on va trop beau chat prendre nous dit
que c'est fini sur calais g51 sajoo 1
après évidemment le fou bessette est
moins intéressant que le x 2 mais
peut-être un cavalier h quatre tours f5
et tours et touré fuite
ouais
et sur cavaliers h3 peut-être tour f 5
puis tourelles fuite peut-être tour f3
après dans mon avis c'est plus si clair
que ça du tout georges et roya d'un
projet cinq exactement c'est la même
idée que le que la tour qui vient en f3
pour pour attaquer le cavalier
tu commences par préférer les noirs plus
je regarde la position et ça lui allait
si toto
je valais a choisi ce que tous rêvent
troyen moi j'aurais été tellement tenter
ainsi de sacrifier la call of fate à
tour avait fuité attaquer j'aurais été
hyper tenter par ce coup et merci après
tu y as qui a offert un abonnement sur
la chaîne merci à toi arrête là
merci merci
bon alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire sarah
ont le match est quasi gagner je pense
qu'il faut faire un point si elle marque
une partie sera finie directement on va
voir combien de temps il reste puisque
en gros il reste combien de temps dans
cette cadence
il reste 2 30 ans elle fêtait là elle
fait b3 et tour f3 d'accord donc comme
ça ça évite est d'alger 5 donc tour
trois forces et elle va faire tour des
huit maintenant elles à prendre 3
prendre trois il y aura normalement
encore une partie derrière celle là donc
ça veut dire qu'il reste de +35 parti il
ya quatre points d'écart et si elle en
gagne une salsa ouais si sarah gagne le
match est terminé
si sarah fait nul c'est pas encore fait
anaky encore un joker nul quoi et qui
doit gagner qu'ils voient et que peut
faire un nul et qui doit tout gagner
cavalier f2 sa kg qu'adam g 5 ml a voulu
réviser à la kdf 6000 points jusqu'à la
perdu le le pion au passage et là il va
voir h5 qui va faire mal croix f7
attaque le cavalier et iliad à me ranger
de en toile de fond alors acquis en
relief trois échecs c'est game ça gagne
la dame elle l'a pas fait mais elle
reste avec une pièce net de plus va
remettre la torah f8 un bien jouer prise
prises et cavaliers f5 d'en prendre
trois peut-être des cats la possible
aussi ça échange m la dame en d4 le
latin 24 pions des 4 l affaire des cats
a mon avis oui menace g2
je pense que le match est terminé 1
parce que cinq points une partie en 3 +
1 il y aura pas plus et ambühl être sûr
à 3 game max comme d'hab c'est game
match qui a plus vraiment d'intérêt
alors l'autre match et ce qui est encore
un intérêt non bah alors là les gars
alors là les amis le le fc ariège qui
est déçu un légat le fc ariège en sueur
dans cette compétition puisque ça joue
plus pour rien il nous reste 25 minutes
ou une demi heure à passer ensemble mais
je sais pas trop quoi vous raconter les
gars parce que bahia plus d'enjeu quoi
les partis vont s'enchaîner mais
pourquoi pour rien quoi c'est vraiment
le défaut de ce format en fait c'est
terrible c'est terrible c'est terrible
trackmania en parallèle loi il faudrait
pouvoir aller faire un truc en parallèle
en voilà on peut pas mais honnêtement
c'est difficile de vous commenter un
truc qui n'a plus d'intérêt quoi ça peut
être facile à sa place de sarba tu veux
fermer le game 1 quant à la place de ça
mais oui tu peux avoir un petit moment
de relâchement apprend bullet pourra
faire gaffe de ne pas faire un cadeau
mais c'est dur
forcément
forcément bon et bien été remontées plus
5 en mai mais le truc c'est que c'est
une question de temps de jeu reste en
vrai c'est qu'on sait qu'à toujours
trois parties en bullet et on sait qu'il
reste qu'une partie dans cette cadence
donc il ya qui reste quatre parties en
vrai donc c'est très difficile de
remonter en fait c'est pas une question
d karkwa deux points puisque +4 ça se
remonte
surtout que le match là dans le contenu
il est assez serré sisters honneur c'est
pas mal aussi pour un harem ça
changerait en fait y'a pas de goal
avérage ya rien là naquit et quand même
tout sourire ça qui est beau malgré la
défaite
elle continue à sourire enfin semi
sourire
c'est beau à voir faire du kitesurf
trois ou quatre on va avoir un petit
détour pour ses cartes ici qui rôde
mais difficile de rester concentré aussi
pourra pour sarah sadate
les los ché skagway mais quand on match
comme ça c'est moins important
l'idée sur fou prend des cats et qui à
tour français dans l'autre match voit
que ça c'est fini on va voir sur quel
score 3 points d'écart vrai que c'est
une tellement plus forte en bullet
donc
à main n'a pas été ridicule ana c'est le
mot le match était plus serrée que le
score ne le score reflète pas le le
match en vraie sarah dominés 1
je pense qu'elle est plus forte mais le
score est un peu sévère
une affaire d'âme g5 je pense parce que
surtout rui tour à tour france et évite
elle commence par tours france élite
la dame d'honneur n'a coûté cher way
la dame en a coûté cher
sarah seront nominés mais ouais les elle
voit vite laiterie quoi elle va vite les
tactiques
il ya aussi la pièce donnée dans la
première partie a directement par
musique zouk qui a pas du tout vu la
pièce en un aussi enfin en deux coups la
petite combine si tu prends ces deux
gaves tu dis qu'il ya un point et demi
pour y avoir deux ennemis quatre ennemis
way serait plus ça bon après elle a
aussi réussi à sauver des parties bon ça
là par contre ça va gagner pour pour
sarah pour pour un à part dont je me
perds et encore un pion qui va tomber
ça fait beaucoup deux pions bombe à leur
actif sarre en fait ça aussi là ok les
forces qui a réussi à bien se réactiver
tous cas dans ce match ça lui aura bien
réussi même ce truc qu'on est
complètement perdante elle réussit à
créer un semblant de danger pour son
adversaire
les menaces mats ek ouvert c'est de
récupérer le le truc ici
f5 a essayé de faire un échec je pense
mais ça mène pas à grand chose
tu es 3g 2 bat contrefaçon fou 4 ça
arrive dam des deux
il ya un vrai ton ami si tous les tons à
sont mixtes crise portait sur un livre
literie mais je sais pas
un live sur bitstream ce soir me trois
rois bouche fou 4-3 bouge d'un bref
quatre voilà il va faire abandonner pour
sarah donc ça va tourner à 4 2 mai mais
comme je lui ai dit devrait y avoir que
trois parties en bullet on va se refaire
une petite pause et comme la dernière
fois on va se vivre la dernière partie
en redif en brie en replay à tout les
gars
alors les gars on va être de retour
poids pour les derniers bullet
c'était calme ouais mais bon c'est la
petite pause les gars la pause était
méritée ne reste plus que plus que le
bullet bon normalement aucun enjeu un
pour ses séries de bull est sympa je
préférais d'en faire des stream
peut-être peut-être sur et des erreurs
décalé je sais pas je vais voir
peut-être keith rim d'échec tête le
vendredi soir on fera plus d'échec on va
faire un peu de multi gaming on fera
peut-être sa part la suite voilà il ya
plus trop d'enjeux on va se regarder ça
tranquillement les gars on s'est déjà
fait une c jaffe des commentaires
enflammés tout à l'heure dans le bullet
tiens quand même à garder ma santé et ma
voix donc on va passer on va pas se
mettre le feu pour on va pas se mettre
le feu pour rien là la coureuse
ukrainienne qui est déjà été rattrapé
par la voiture balai on va laisser on va
laisser le truc se jouer tranquille on
va être spectateur est pas forcément
acteurs n'en a pas rajouté des coudes et
des tonnes de toute façon on sait ce qui
va se passer
j'ai dit pas bon de trop et ouais bien
joué bien jouer mathieu on va voir sarah
sadate fermer le fermer la game si elle
le peut juste pas qu'elle abandonne way
normalement seule chance pour anna s'est
joué très très vite et c'est de gagner
une partie rapidement sa seule chance
mais sarah faut jusqu'à jouent tous
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au match si elle le
fait c'est fini sketches s'enflammer
quand tu as le groupe de sprinteurs qui
passe la ligne d'arrivée sur le tournage
45 minutes plus tard et voilà c'est ça
c'est que là malheureusement aller c'est
bien là ce que fait ce que fait un ajout
h 4 1 elle tente quelque chose au moins
elle tente quelque chose
elle doit elle doit gagner vite elle
doit gagner vite elle doit gagner alors
il ya quoi y'a 3 si ça doit gagner
article 3 minutes en gros donc c'est
faisable si elle se s'il reste bien
autant à chaque fois donc c'est
exactement ce qu'elle fait elle joue
tout tempo en tout cas anaky qui connaît
les règles du jeu et qui les emploient à
son avantage
sauf que là on voulant jouer vite
malheureusement elle fait du cac à ce
qui est souvent le cas
elle perd le pion des 4 et maintenant
elle va perdre
fall a perdu un point à la paire du
matériel tailleur fou prend avec trois
pions pour avec 3 qui est prend b3 et
donc en voulant gagner vite elle peut se
retrouver avec le problème de ne pas
gagner du tout ce qui serait encore plus
grave pour elle on va avoir un vrai
petit rock ici qu'à value8 ça change
parce que pour elle il faut aussi que la
partie dure pas trop de coups bas quand
même beaucoup de beaucoup de si beaucoup
de conditions pour que pour cana puisse
remonter mais en tout cas ils tentent
elles tant elle tentait le temps que le
patou elles montrent le roi il va y
avoir quoi 4 ça attaque bekkat à trois
peut-être peut-être dames 6 aussi vous
faire dame b3 assez intéressant f6 elle
blinde
mais malheureusement c'est dur
d'accélérer là pour pour anna les
secondes s'égrènent facile sur le papier
à dire qu'il faut tout jouer tempo mais
c'est plus dur à faire en réalité c'est
même plutôt sahara qui prend l'avantagé
au temps elle a donc là le match est
vraiment va vraiment être plié de chez
plié il va même puis à voir le frisson
d'un d'une semi d'un quart de chances
afr b3 à tout prix qu'elle a réussi à
cacher le roi elle a réussi à se
défendre ana c'est déjà pas mal
non elle va attaquer de l'autre côté on
est déjà au 30e coup je pense que le
pion à 6 elle va essayer de le prendre
mais pour le moment il ya cinq ans l'est
cavalier c7 elle va essayer de rejaillir
vers la case des 5 c'est chose faite
mais elle donne un pion le pion dessins
qu'elle va récupérer h6 bon ça reste
quand même assez bien pour pour les
noirs j'imagine le pion à deux émirats
d'un pro f 5 3 h 8 dames e cat attaque
la tourelle fait un bon enchaînement la
anna la dame qui vient est ce qu'elle va
prendre des six mois elle prend à deux
prises trois prises f3 prise f3 pris ces
trois j'imagine oui c'est chose faite
c'est un tour des cinq tours c'est 2 3 à
3 tours prend elle va prendre ici il va
y avoir tour deux tours b 8,3 bouche bée
5 es et tu vas pas pouvoir arrêter le
pion par derrière et anna du coup qui va
gagner la partie mais où il faut pas que
sarah abandonne là bien sûr ce serait
vraiment stupide
fola il faut jouer le maximum de coups
alors là il ya des huit matin on a raté
à c'est dommage ça pour ana sara qui
emploie les conseils du coach allait
tout reprend pions pour jouer le maximum
de coups ou touraille fuite bien joué
tombé huit c'est dommage pour jeu
beaucoup de coups non mais faut pas
abandonner là c'est stupide assez
terrible c'est terrible cet abandon
stérile il fallait donner la tour
conques le pion et jouer un maximum de
coups ouais bon samedi c'est pas très
grave parce que la partie a quand même
duré très longtemps mais c'est c'est
dommage
tu dois pas faire ça il reste combien de
temps je vais essayer d'aller à
l'échoppé un chrono c'est aller choper
le choper le chrono de chess comme
officiel le vent tournant le vent tourne
pas du tout il ya encore il reste que rs
6 minutes
ouais là elle a joué plus de trois
minutes la première partie et dans
l'autre match il ya eu quoi je suis en
train d'essayer de choper le le résultat
de l'autre partie en même temps il ya eu
nulle dans l'aude
denrées dans l'autre match est vraiment
fini fini la partie a duré super
longtemps et il ya eu nulle ce match là
il ya encore un tout petit espoir pour
pour anna qui attaquent à fond elle elle
sait s'il faut qu'elle fasse au montana
elle donne tout mais elle envoie le pion
à challes essaye de faire un match
rapide si elle le peut pour pour se
sauver de ce mauvais pas mais elle
pourra regretter les occasions manquées
notamment cette dame données en un dans
une position gagnante sûrs et que 5 4 1
au final le match serait très très serré
a quand même fait beaucoup d'erreurs
simples qu'elles payent au prix cher
la joueuse ukrainienne la tour qui part
ans c'est dans ces 1 dames 17f quatre
cavaliers qui va devoir venir en gkd
j'imagine fou prend pions prend et food
et 4 ça paraît cool ça fait dame ces
deux pour dams et 7 c'est très cool
aussi de nouveaux sahara avec un petit
avantage
ben tu vas rentrer et peut-être même en
sait si ce n'est peut-être ses sets je
sais pas le long de la colonne s'est en
tout cas elle prend d'un proxy ces dames
c4as les tours 8 dame prend tout reprend
tour ces quatre des cinq quand même
faire gaffe
pour ces quatre des cinq tours ces huit
trois sets 3 f 7
elle aura eu 5 ça va aller pour pour
sarah elle fait pas cinq alès le pion
aux quatre ans l'air assez bizarre ça ne
pas ne pas l'avoir sauvée et maintenant
c'est chaud c'est incroyable elle se met
elle se met le feu tout seul ça elle se
met le feu tout seul parti qui est pas
super longue en termes de coûts encore
elle en train de se faire remonter
incroyable
le roi qui repart et l'a peut-être un
fou des 4 suivi des deux et ça a l'air
bien fini c'est terrible c'est
incroyable ce qu'on est en train de
vivre les amis à d1 dames est la tour
des huit as well as 1000 euros en
dix-sept c'était la faute
ouais le retournement de situation sarah
qui a fait tourner tourner tourner le
truc on va remettre les calmes way est
donc là c'est vraiment à là c'est
vraiment fini ça y est faut juste être
un peu un peu précis j'ai envie d'air de
toute façon la partie là qui va durer
des plombes ne peut pas faire ni leroy
gyan ne peut pas répéter les coups si
elle répète le match est fini fini et
elle répète et donc ça y est sarah
sahara qui gagne le match qui a encore
retourné une partie et alexandra c'est
gagner aussi donc écouter on a on a nos
demi-finalistes donc on va remettre le
tableau donc oui fans qui jouera contre
sara comme la semaine passée et
un petit koné roux qui jouera contre
alexandra kosteniuk continue qui sera la
grande favorite de cette demi finale et
qui aura donc toutes ses chances pour se
qualifier pour la finale de ce grand
prix et donc pour la finale des grands
prix
c'est difficile pour sarah contre
contrecoup yifan mais c'est faisable on
verra ce que ça donne en tout cas elle
est encore en demi finale pour la
troisième fois en autant de
participations c'est un bon résultat là
comme je vous dire maintenant deux
parties se seraient le maximum il ya
trois points des cas d'écart et
normalement c'est la dernière donc il ya
vraiment plus aucune chance de voir un
retournement de situation là même une
déconnexion ne changerait pas le match
c'est terrible de façon je vous diront
ce n'est pas trop d'illusions au début
de la section du latin là juste par
curiosité si elle avait pu gagner
l'autre partie reste combien de temps
jeu juste par curiosité est ce que est
ce que si elle avait gagné l'autre ça
aurait pu il aurait pu se passer quoi
que ce soit ou pas il reste une minute
là deux matches wen en bon il reste une
minute de match et ça va encore 35
secondes
j'ai envie de dire quoi qu'il en soit
ils pouvaient ils pouvaient rien se
passer
le match était fini avant la cadence a
bullet et soir je fais quoi ce soir je
serai peut-être un peu des blitz les
schémas si j'ai de la force encore je
verrai comment ça se passe puisque j'ai
fait pas mal de parties en parlant à fab
en attendant des trucs faut remonter le
vélo à 2007 là j'ai perdu mon élan en
faisant n'importe quoi en fait en
meublant en discutant d'autres choses
ces deux matches qu'il a un bonnet lo à
27,20 et j'ai laissé tomber comme ça moi
je joue aussi deux fois contre un gars
qui semblait gruger ça coûtait aussi je
pense faire un petit truc paix pousée
demain
et demain si alive il y aura lie
normalement mais ce sera sera pas des
échecs tuera peut-être maxime et on leur
donne le nom je pense pas qu'il redonne
le vélo je pense était contre un gars
malin tout cas j'en ai plein qui devrait
redonner du vélo mais a dernièrement
vous avez vu qu'il ya eu une énorme
déflation sur czech comme et je pense
que c'est dû à ça il ya plein de gars
malins qui font de la merde et donc et
donc ça fait une déflation massif sur
check up en fait pour voir ce match est
terminé l'autre match j'ai envie de vous
dire je sais pas mais bon voilà on va
regarder enfin ça aucun intérieur façon
assez c'est fini donc vous retrouver
faber andrea vendredi demain pour les
demi-finales et moi je serai là pour la
finale dimanche
façon est facile à la fin de cette
partie mais il ya cinq points d'écart
moi j'ai rien à vous dire la source est
reparti de soissons et à tour qui arrive
en bessette sur dame prend bessette et
qu'elle prend bessette ça gagne la dame
sait pas trop pourquoi elle avait pas vu
arriver à le penser qu'à et puis on
prend un tour prend 1,8 et on prend un
pardon mais de toute façon c'était fini
il ya 9 3 ça sert à rien de continuer ma
le match s'arrête donc bravo aux
joueuses qui l'ont emporté et on se
retrouve on se retrouve ce soir du coup
et surtout demain mais à voir je vous
promets pas un gros niveau ce soir je
vais faire ce que je fais là j'ai encore
une réunion un machin c'est fou c'est
long donc je vous souhaite à tous bas
dans mon début de soirée puis toi sont
smara ensemble je suis passion ça jouera
bien mon s'amusera merci à tous ciao
ciao